When West Jet first took flight in 1996, the vibes were a bit different. People thought denim on denim was peak fashion, inline skates were everywhere, and two out of three women rocked, the Rachel. While those things stayed in the 90s, one thing that hasn't is that fuzzy feeling you get when WestJet welcomes you on board. Here's to WestJetting since 96. Travel back in time with us and actually travel with us at westjet.com slash 30 years. Marvel Television's Wonder Man, an eight-episode series. Now streaming on Disney Plus.
1996年西捷航空首航时，氛围有些不同。当时人们认为牛仔配牛仔是时尚巅峰，轮滑鞋随处可见，三分之二的女性都留着“瑞秋头”。虽然这些事物留在了90年代，但有一点从未改变，那就是当你踏上西捷航空航班时感受到的那种温馨。为西捷航空自96年以来的飞行干杯。和我们一起穿越回过去，并真正与我们同行，请访问 westjet.com/30years。漫威电视出品的《神奇人》，八集系列剧。现已在 Disney Plus 上线。
A superhero remake. Not exactly what we'd expect from an Oscar winning director. Action! Simon Williams, audition for Wonder Man. I'm going to need you to sign this. Assuming you don't have superpowers. I'll never work again if anyone found out. My lips are sealed.
一部超级英雄翻拍剧。这可不是我们对一位奥斯卡获奖导演的期待。开拍！西蒙·威廉姆斯，为《神奇人》试镜。我需要你签这份文件。假设你没有超能力。如果有人发现，我就再也无法工作了。我会守口如瓶的。
Marvel Television's Wonder Man. All eight episodes now streaming. Only on Disney Plus. Getting ready for a game means being ready for anything. Like packing a spare stick. I like to be prepared. That's why I remember 988, Canada's suicide crisis helpline. It's good to know, just in case.
漫威电视出品的《神奇人》。全八集现已上线。仅在 Disney Plus 播出。为比赛做准备意味着要为任何情况做好准备。比如多带一根球杆。我喜欢有备无患。这就是为什么我记住了 988，加拿大的自杀危机求助热线。以防万一，了解一下总没坏处。
Anyone can call or text for free confidential support from a train responder anytime. 988 suicide crisis helpline is funded by the government in Canada. Most honoured, madam. Since while I'm staying in your house, I'm obliged to spend several hours a day in the strictest solitude, tell me, I beg you, whether you wish me to submit fully to this isolation, or else to do so within limits set by you. And supposing that you wish me to stay confined to my bedroom, then do not, I beg you, require me to serve as my own sentry,
任何人都可以随时拨打或发送短信，获得训练有素的接线员提供的免费保密支持。988 自杀危机求助热线由加拿大政府资助。夫人，万分荣幸。既然我住在您的府上，且有义务每天花几个小时进行最严格的独处，请您务必告诉我，您是希望我完全服从这种隔离，还是在您设定的范围内进行。如果您希望我被限制在卧室里，那么我恳求您，不要让我充当自己的守卫，
but rather take steps yourself to make sure that I cannot leave my room. This will cost you no more trouble than the turning of a key in the door twice a day. I submit to you as my mistress, so that I may be bolstered in my weakness by your judgment and your vision. vigilance. I wish my patroness always to be sensible of that authority which you wheeled over me, and to be held by you in that slivary which you know so well how to make a happy one. So that was a letter written by Samuel Johnson, a man of course of the Midlands, as people can tell from that reading. But he wrote it originally in French. And he wrote it a few months before he left on his
而是亲自采取措施，确保我无法离开房间。这不会给您带来比每天转动两次门锁更多的麻烦。我作为您的仆人服从于您，这样我就可以在您的判断和远见卓识下，弥补我的软弱。警惕。我希望我的女主人始终能意识到您对我行使的权威，并让我保持在您所熟知的、那种令人愉悦的奴役状态中。所以，那是一封塞缪尔·约翰逊写的信，正如人们从那段朗读中听出的那样，他当然是一位来自中部地区的人。但他最初是用法语写的。那是他在离开去
tour to the Hebrides with James Boswell in August 1773. So, listeners who have followed us in this epic series will know that on that tour, Johnson was in splendid form. There was a lot of Caledonian ribaldry. There was a lot of general banter. There was a lot of sulking while riding down mountains on ponies. There was a lot of actually him being surprisingly nice about Scotland, which is something we always try to do on the rest is history. But this, Dr. Johnson, in his letter, this is a very different character. He's back to his old eccentric ways. He's a bit awkward, isn't he?
赫布里底群岛旅行前的几个月写的，那是1773年8月与詹姆斯·博斯韦尔同行。所以，关注我们这个史诗系列的听众会知道，在那次旅行中，约翰逊状态极佳。有很多苏格兰式的粗俗笑话。有很多日常的调侃。有很多骑着矮种马下山时的闷闷不乐。还有很多他实际上对苏格兰出人意料地友好的表现，这也是我们在《历史的其余部分》中一直尝试做的事情。但这位约翰逊博士，在这封信里，是一个非常不同的人物。他又回到了他那古怪的老样子。他有点尴尬，不是吗？
And he's very submissive. So what's going on here, Tom? Why is he like this? And to whom is he writing? Well, I think that letter is a reminder that the Johnson that we get from Boswell is not the only Johnson. that there are people who actually are seeing Johnson far more often than Boswell does, and that these people perhaps are aware of entire aspects of Johnson's character that Boswell at this point can really only guess at.
而且他非常顺从。那么，汤姆，这到底是怎么回事？他为什么会这样？他在给谁写信？嗯，我认为那封信提醒我们，我们从博斯韦尔那里了解到的约翰逊并不是唯一的约翰逊。实际上有些人比博斯韦尔更频繁地见到约翰逊，这些人或许了解约翰逊性格的完整侧面，而博斯韦尔在这一点上真的只能猜测。
And of all the people who knew Samuel Johnson in the final decades of his life, the one who knew him probably, well, not probably, I mean, certainly knew him best, was the recipient of that letter which you read out so sonorously and splendidly. And this is a woman who was over 30 years younger than Johnson, and she was called Mrs. Thrail. And there are people who complain that there is far too much Welsh history on this podcast. But I'm afraid that sometimes it just can't be helped, because Mrs. Thrail was Welsh and she was born Hester Lynch Salisbury and she belonged to one of the most kind of illustrious property-owning families in Wales.
在塞缪尔·约翰逊生命最后几十年里认识他的所有人中，那位最了解他的人——嗯，不是可能，我是说，肯定最了解他的人——正是你刚才朗读得如此响亮而精彩的那封信的收信人。这是一位比约翰逊年轻30多岁的女性，她叫思拉尔夫人。有些人抱怨这个播客里的威尔士历史太多了。但我恐怕有时也无可奈何，因为思拉尔夫人是威尔士人，她原名海丝特·林奇·索尔兹伯里，属于威尔士最显赫的地产家族之一。
Very distinguished pedigree, in fact so distinguished that the Salisbury's claim descent from Henry the 7th, who was of course famously Welsh. So there is a slight kind of Jane Austen narrative, however, with the young Hester Thrail in her childhood because her parents, although they have this pedigree, are starting to run out of money. Her father is very grand, but very incompetent with cash. And so, of course, what do you do in a situation like that? If you're the mother, you start looking around for a suitable husband. And so this is what Mrs. Salisbury does. She goes to the full Mrs. Bennett. And she finds a suitable husband for her young daughter in the form of a guy called Henry Thrail, who is the son of a London brewer. and the brewery stood in Southwark pretty much directly on the site of what had been Shakespeare's Globe Theatre.
血统非常高贵，事实上高贵到索尔兹伯里家族声称是亨利七世的后裔，而亨利七世当然是著名的威尔士人。然而，年轻的海丝特·思拉尔的童年确实有一种简·奥斯汀式叙事的味道，因为她的父母虽然有这种血统，但钱快花光了。她的父亲非常显赫，但对金钱非常无能。所以，在这种情况下你会怎么做？如果你是母亲，你就会开始寻找合适的丈夫。这就是索尔兹伯里夫人所做的。她完全展现了班内特夫人的风范。她为年轻的女儿找到了一个合适的丈夫，一个叫亨利·思拉尔的人，他是伦敦一位酿酒商的儿子。酿酒厂位于南华克，几乎就在莎士比亚环球剧院的原址上。
So right on the banks of the Thames. And Thrail was a very cold, reserved man. He was over a decade older than Hester. But saliently from Mrs. Salsby's point of view, he's fabulously rich. You know, he has great expectations. Hester herself, I mean, you know, she's not remotely attracted to him. She barely met him. And her father's appalled because he doesn't want his daughter marrying someone in trade,
就在泰晤士河畔。思拉尔是一个非常冷漠、矜持的人。他比海丝特大十多岁。但从索尔兹伯里夫人的角度来看，最重要的是，他极其富有。你知道，他前途无量。海丝特本人，我是说，你知道，她对他一点也不感兴趣。她几乎没见过他。她的父亲感到震惊，因为他不希望女儿嫁给一个从事贸易的人，
particularly not in brewing. But he dies very abruptly before he can stop the marriage negotiations. Mrs. Salisbury is absolutely determined because she doesn't want to lose all her cash. And so the marriage goes ahead. Hester, Salsbury becomes Hester Thrail, marries this guy, this brewer. And so today's episode, we're going to be excited. exploring the tangled relationship of Samuel Johnson and Mrs. Thoreau. And indeed, James Boswell. Yes. She's very funny. And she has the kind of humour that just occasionally goes to perhaps the limits and occasionally over it.
尤其是酿酒业。但他还没来得及阻止婚事谈判就突然去世了。索尔兹伯里夫人非常坚定，因为她不想失去所有的钱。于是婚姻继续进行。海丝特·索尔兹伯里变成了海丝特·思拉尔，嫁给了这个家伙，这个酿酒商。所以今天的节目，我们将要探索塞缪尔·约翰逊和思拉尔夫人之间纠葛的关系。当然，还有詹姆斯·博斯韦尔。是的。她非常风趣。她有一种偶尔会达到极限，甚至偶尔越界的幽默感。
That's the best kind of humour. And she's also very, very smart. So she's very widely read. She's fluent of French, Spanish, and Italian. And her fluency in Italian will be a detail that people perhaps should keep in mind. She's also very familiar with the classics. So, Latin and Greek to a degree that's unusual for women at the time. And of course, Samuel Johnson, you know, he's a great Latinist in particular. So lots of scope there for chat. And she's locked in this essentially, it's pretty unhappy marriage, I think. There isn't any great spark between her and her husband. And Mr. Thrail, he's simultaneously a philanderer. So he has lots of mistresses, but also he's just endlessly keeping his wife pregnant. I mean, she ends up having 12 pregnancies. So you can see why she might think, oh, you know, I'd like to spread my wings. I would like to meet new people, to have discussions that don't revolve around beer.
那是最好的幽默。而且她也非常、非常聪明。她博览群书。她精通法语、西班牙语和意大利语。她对意大利语的精通将是一个人们或许应该记住的细节。她对古典文学也非常熟悉。所以，她对拉丁语和希腊语的掌握程度在当时的女性中是不寻常的。当然，塞缪尔·约翰逊，你知道，他尤其是一位伟大的拉丁学者。所以有很多聊天空间。而且她被困在这段本质上我认为非常不幸的婚姻中。她和丈夫之间没有任何火花。而思拉尔先生，他同时也是个风流成性的人。所以他有很多情妇，但他也不断地让妻子怀孕。我是说，她最终经历了12次怀孕。所以你可以看出为什么她可能会想，哦，你知道，我想展翅高飞。我想结识新朋友，进行不围绕啤酒展开的讨论。
And it has to be said, actually, that Henry Thrail is notably taciturn. But he also is keen to kind of elevate himself. And so when Mrs. Thrail gets an opening, she meets Samuel John. Johnson, who is probably by this point the most famous person in London. And she invites him to come and have dinner with them on a Thursday evening in their house in Southwark, next to the brewery. And Johnson's delighted to come. It's not far. Just cross the Thames from Fleet Street and you're there. And he is delighted.
而且必须说，事实上，亨利·思拉尔特别沉默寡言。但他也很热衷于提升自己的地位。所以当思拉尔夫人得到一个机会时，她遇到了塞缪尔·约翰逊，他当时可能是伦敦最出名的人。她邀请他周四晚上到他们在南华克、酿酒厂旁边的家里吃晚饭。约翰逊很高兴能来。离得不远。穿过泰晤士河从弗利特街过来就到了。他非常高兴。
He thinks Mrs. Strel is great. I mean, he's this great kind of awkward, shambling man in his 50s, kind of twitching and everything. and here is this very attractive, very charming young woman in her 20s, who also has a sensational chef in the house, so can provide him with lots of amazing food. So he thinks he's on to an absolute winner. Johnson, of course, is a great conversationalist. Henry Thrail is famously not a great conversation list,
他觉得思拉尔夫人很棒。我是说，他是一个50多岁、笨拙、步履蹒跚、抽搐着什么的伟大人物，而这里有一位20多岁、非常有吸引力、非常有魅力的年轻女性，家里还有一位出色的厨师，能为他提供许多美味的食物。所以他认为自己中了大奖。约翰逊当然是一位伟大的谈话家。亨利·思拉尔以不善言辞而闻名，
but because Johnson feels grateful towards both the Thrails, Mr Thrail as well as Mrs. Thrail, he doesn't make a great song and dance about this. And actually he's for Johnson. quite polite about it. So he says about Henry Thrail, his conversation may not show the minute hand, but he strikes the hour very correctly, which I think is admirably expressed. So he's going every Thursday to dinner, and Johnson's quite lonely. He's constantly troubled by depression. He's always in danger of falling into the sort of the black pit, isn't he? And is this a way of
但因为约翰逊对两位思拉尔夫妇——思拉尔先生和思拉尔夫人——都心存感激，他并没有对此大惊小怪。事实上，对于约翰逊来说，他对此相当客气。所以他评价亨利·思拉尔说：“他的谈话可能不显示分针，但他报时非常准确”，我认为这表达得令人钦佩。所以他每周四都去吃晚饭，约翰逊相当孤独。他一直被抑郁所困扰。他总是处于陷入那种黑色深渊的危险中，不是吗？这是某种方式吗？
staving that off, do you think? I think almost certainly because this is a period in his life where he seems to be sinking back into the mood of extreme melancholy that had characterized his after he'd left Oxford. So when he was much younger, a period when he had been worried about going mad, that he was so depressed that he might kind of end up killing himself. And this is a period where he seems burdened by very dark emotions of guilt and regret. And his tics, his OCD, is becoming really, really very obvious to everyone.
你认为这是在抵御那种情绪吗？我认为几乎可以肯定，因为这是他生命中一段似乎正在沉回那种极度忧郁情绪的时期，这种情绪在他离开牛津后就一直伴随着他。所以当他年轻得多的时候，那段时期他曾担心自己会发疯，他非常抑郁，以至于可能最终会自杀。这是一个他似乎被非常黑暗的内疚和遗憾情绪所困扰的时期。他的抽动症，他的强迫症，对每个人来说都变得非常、非常明显。
So he walks down a street, he's got a stick. He cannot walk down the street without touching every. kind of post or bollard along the street. And if he misses one, he has to go back. If he walks through a doorway into a room and then back out again, he has to do it in exactly the same number of steps. If he's peeling an orange, then he has to keep the peel and put it in his pocket. So, I mean, these are all kind of very, very striking for his friends. It's alarming to them because he does seem he seems unhappy. But the thing about Johnson is that he's not someone for sharing his unhappiness. He puts on a brave front.
所以他走在街上，拿着一根棍子。他走在街上时，如果不摸一下路边的每一根柱子或护柱，就无法继续走。如果他漏掉了一个，他就得回去。如果他走进一个房间又走出来，他必须以完全相同的步数完成。如果他在剥橘子，他就必须保留橘子皮并放进兜里。所以，我是说，这些对他朋友来说都非常、非常引人注目。这让他们感到担忧，因为他看起来确实很不快乐。但约翰逊的问题在于，他不是那种会分享自己不幸的人。他表现得很勇敢。
And this is a period. You say he's lonely. I mean, maybe, but at the same time, he's going out to the club. He's dining with all his friends. He's a very clubbable man, all of this. But I think in private, he is worried that he might be going mad to the extent that he worries that he will end up in an asylum chained up, which is what happens to lunatics, as they're called in this period.
这是一个时期。你说他很孤独。我是说，也许吧，但与此同时，他正在去俱乐部。他和所有的朋友一起用餐。他是一个非常喜欢社交的人，所有这些。但我认为在私下里，他担心自己可能会发疯，以至于担心自己最终会被关进疯人院，被锁起来，这就是那个时期所谓的疯子会发生的事情。
You go to bedlam and they're kind of part of the tourism industry, go and have a gorp at them. And there's a wonderful biography of Johnson, not by Boswell, but by a great American scholar, Walter Jackson, Bate. And he describes it. He says, finally, in exhausted despair, Johnson bought fetters and padlocks, lest the enemy that seemed to be winning against him passed beyond control, so his depression. It was a sign not only of shattered self-confidence, but of a fearful self-condemnation. So he's almost going to chain and padlock himself. I think he's worried that he may end up so mad that he's going to need to. someone to padlock him up. That's exactly what he's worrying about. And Boswell comes back from his
你去贝特莱姆皇家医院，他们就像旅游业的一部分，去看看他们。有一本关于约翰逊的精彩传记，不是博斯韦尔写的，而是由一位伟大的美国学者沃尔特·杰克逊·贝特写的。他描述了这一点。他说，最终，在精疲力竭的绝望中，约翰逊买了镣铐和挂锁，以免那个似乎正在战胜他的敌人失去控制，也就是他的抑郁症。这不仅是自信心破碎的标志，也是一种可怕的自我谴责。所以他几乎要给自己上镣铐和挂锁。我想他担心自己最终会变得如此疯狂，以至于需要有人把他锁起来。这正是他所担心的。博斯韦尔从他的
great tour in February 1766. But even though they're great pals, Johnson doesn't confide in him. There's no sort of better help aspect to the Johnson Boswell friendship. No, well, we said, I mean, Johnson is not a man for going on about his bad mental health. He keeps quiet about it. Princess William and Harry would not approve of him. No, I don't think they would. But he does talk about, he kind of hints about his unhappiness to his new friends, the thrales. And remember, Boswell is barely with Johnson. He comes back, he meets up, you know, they go around, and then Boswell is back to Scotland. But Johnson is going to see the thrales every Thursday. So there's a kind of regularity there. And I think he does confess to them something of his unhappiness. And one morning,
伟大旅行中于1766年2月回来。但尽管他们是好哥们，约翰逊并没有向他吐露心声。约翰逊和博斯韦尔的友谊中没有那种心理咨询的成分。不，嗯，我们说过，我是说，约翰逊不是那种会谈论自己糟糕心理健康的人。他对此保持沉默。威廉王子和哈里王子不会赞同他的做法。不，我不认为他们会。但他确实谈到了，他暗示了自己的不幸给他的新朋友，思拉尔夫妇。记住，博斯韦尔几乎不和约翰逊在一起。他回来，他们见面，你知道，他们四处走动，然后博斯韦尔又回到了苏格兰。但约翰逊每周四都会去见思拉尔夫妇。所以那里有一种规律性。而且我认为他确实向他们坦白了一些他的不幸。有一天早上，
the thrales, you know, they cross from Southwark and they go to his rooms, which are just off Fleet Street, and they go in and there they find him on his knees in the grip of a full blown breakdown. He's kneeling before a clergyman who is standing there looking kind of mortified and embarrassed, doesn't really know what to do. And he is kind of babbling and sobbing and almost he seems on the verge of insanity, I guess you could say. And he's accusing himself of things, no, isn't it? He's lambasting himself about supposed sins or crimes is committed or whatever these might be.
思拉尔夫妇，你知道，他们从南华克穿过来，去了他在弗利特街附近的房间，他们走进去，发现他跪在地上，正处于全面崩溃的状态。他跪在一个牧师面前，牧师站在那里，看起来很尴尬，不知道该怎么办。他正在胡言乱语、啜泣，几乎处于疯狂的边缘，我想你可以这么说。他在指责自己，不是吗？他在抨击自己犯下的所谓罪行或过错，无论这些可能是什么。
Well, he's kind of hinting at all sorts of dark secrets. And the thrales walk in, the clergyman said, oh, thank God you're here and basically rushes out. And the fact that the thrales are there and Johnson obviously trusts them means that he is ready to unburden himself perhaps in a way that he hadn't even been with the clergyman. But he's still not really making sense. He's kind of gabbling over his words, very unusual for Johnson. And Mrs. Thrail would later, you know, she'd write. this incident up and she said, I felt excessively affected with grief. And well remember, my husband involuntarily lifted up one hand to shut his mouth. You know, he is talking so wildly.
嗯，他暗示了各种黑暗的秘密。思拉尔夫妇走进来，牧师说，哦，感谢上帝你们来了，然后基本上冲了出去。思拉尔夫妇在那里，而约翰逊显然信任他们，这意味着他准备好倾诉自己，这或许是他甚至没有对牧师做到的。但他仍然没有说出什么有意义的话。他语无伦次，这对于约翰逊来说非常不寻常。思拉尔夫人后来，你知道，她写下了这件事，她说，我感到极度的悲伤。而且我清楚地记得，我丈夫不由自主地抬起一只手捂住他的嘴。你知道，他说话太疯狂了。
And Mr. Threll can't stay because he's got business demands. But before he leaves Johnson's quarters and goes back out into the street, he tells his wife, bring Johnson not to our townhouse, so the house in Suffolk, but bring him out of London to our country retreat. And so this is what Mrs. Thrail does. And where is this delightful country retreat? Well, it's in the picturesque little village of Streatham. Right. Which is charming, delightful trees, cows, all of that.
思拉尔先生不能留下来，因为他有业务需求。但在他离开约翰逊的住处回到街上之前，他告诉妻子，不要把约翰逊带到我们的联排别墅，也就是南华克的房子，而是把他带出伦敦，带到我们的乡村度假地。于是思拉尔夫人就这样做了。这个令人愉快的乡村度假地在哪里呢？嗯，它在风景如画的斯特里汉姆小村庄。对。那里有迷人、令人愉快的树木、奶牛，所有这些。
Anyone who lives in South London today will know that Streatham High Street won an award as Britain's ugliest street. So there's been quite a change since then. Right. But back then, it's very kind of silven and beautiful. And the Thrails live in this gorgeous house. It's a kind of massive three-story mansion called Streaton Park. It's got 100 acres of land. It's got spreading lawns.
今天住在伦敦南部的任何人都知道，斯特里汉姆大街曾获得英国最丑街道的奖项。所以从那时起已经发生了很大的变化。对。但在那时，它非常宁静而美丽。思拉尔夫妇住在这座华丽的房子里。这是一座巨大的三层豪宅，叫斯特里汉姆公园。它有100英亩的土地。它有广阔的草坪。
It's got gardens. It's got greenhouses. All kinds of fruit is growing there. So melons and peaches. And this for Johnson, I mean, it's mind-blowing. You know, this is a guy who's lived all his life basically in poverty. And what the thrales are giving him is an experience of seclusion and essentially luxury that is something that he's never experienced before. So he's a valued house guest, isn't he? He's not a patient. He's given the best food. He can, you know, charge back the house and gardens to his heart's content.
它有花园。它有温室。各种水果都在那里生长。所以甜瓜和桃子。这对约翰逊来说，我是说，这太令人震惊了。你知道，这是一个一生基本上都在贫困中度过的人。而思拉尔夫妇给他的是一种他从未体验过的隐居和本质上的奢华体验。所以他是一位受重视的房客，不是吗？他不是病人。他得到了最好的食物。他可以，你知道，随心所欲地在房子和花园里充电。
Eat peaches? He loves peaches. As many peaches as you could eat. Well, also, peaches don't have peel. Oh, so you're fine with your OCD. And crucially, Mrs. Thrail, he has a real sort of fondness for Mrs. Thrill, doesn't he? A tondress, yes. And she, you know, he can do no wrong for her. Like, as eccentric and as, as, as, you know, as fondness. weirdly as he behaves. She will sit up late with him and she'll bring him tea
吃桃子？他喜欢桃子。你能吃多少就吃多少。嗯，而且桃子没有皮。哦，所以你的强迫症就没问题了。而且至关重要的是，思拉尔夫人，他对思拉尔夫人有一种真正的喜爱，不是吗？一种温柔，是的。而且她，你知道，他做的一切对她来说都是对的。就像，无论他表现得多么古怪、多么奇怪。她会和他坐到很晚，她会给他端茶
and she, isn't there something to do with his wig? He almost sets his wig on fire. Yeah, so the servants will bring him candles and he'll kind of become so attentive with the book he's reading that his wig will drop forward and burst into flames. And so they fix it that a servant will stand outside the door holding his wig. And then if he needs it again, you know, he can call for it.
而且，关于他的假发是不是有什么事？他差点把假发点着了。是的，所以仆人会给他拿蜡烛，他会变得非常专注于他正在读的书，以至于他的假发会向前掉落并着火。所以他们安排了一个仆人站在门外拿着他的假发。然后如果他需要它，你知道，他可以叫它。
So they're very kind of very attentive to him. They even provide him with a coach. If he wants to go back into London, he can use that. And so unsurprisingly, he does start to recover his spirits. And as the months and then the years go by, he starts to think of strutton place almost as a kind of home. I mean, he's not there all the time. He's still got his rooms, you know, back in London off Fleet Street. But he is starting to become a real fixture.
所以他们对他非常、非常体贴。他们甚至为他提供了一辆马车。如果他想回伦敦，他可以使用它。所以不出所料，他确实开始恢复精神了。随着几个月甚至几年的过去，他开始把斯特里汉姆庄园几乎看作是一个家。我是说，他并不总是待在那里。他仍然有他的房间，你知道，在伦敦弗利特街后面。但他开始成为一个真正的常客。
He has his own room. And he feels wanted and admired. And so obviously that cheers him up. I mean, of course it would. They invite all his mates out for dinner, and they, all the people from the club, so Burke and Garrick and Joshua Reynolds and this is good news for the Thrails, because basically their Thrails have got Johnson there. Their dining table has become one of the most celebrated in England.
他有自己的房间。他感到被需要和被钦佩。所以显然这让他振作起来。我是说，当然会。他们邀请他所有的伙伴出来吃晚饭，他们，所有来自俱乐部的人，所以伯克、加里克和约书亚·雷诺兹，这对思拉尔夫妇来说是个好消息，因为基本上他们的思拉尔夫妇把约翰逊留在了那里。他们的餐桌已经成为英国最著名的餐桌之一。
Yeah, because Johnson is the great literary lion of London. And for Mr Threll in particular, who never says anything, it's amazing to have Burke and Johnson, Garrick and Reynolds and all these kind of tremendous wits around his table. Yeah. Basically, it's a quid pro quo. Johnson gets loads of peaches and has someone to hold his wig outside his window. And Mr. Thrail becomes the host of this incredible social circle.
是的，因为约翰逊是伦敦伟大的文学狮子。对于思拉尔先生来说，他从不说话，有伯克和约翰逊、加里克和雷诺兹以及所有这些了不起的才子围在他的餐桌旁真是太棒了。是的。基本上，这是一种交换条件。约翰逊得到了大量的桃子，还有人帮他在窗外拿着假发。而思拉尔先生则成为了这个不可思议的社交圈的主人。
It's obvious, I think, that it's not just the home comforts that Johnson loves. He also loves the sense of family because he hadn't had any children himself and Mrs. Thrail has hundreds of children. And in fact, Johnson seems to have. got on better with Mrs. Thrail's enormous brood of children than Mrs. Thrail did herself. So she was kind of erratically affectionate. She might suddenly kind of, you know, smother a child with kisses. But I think most of the time she found her children very boring. Johnson, by contrast, thinks they're great. I mean, he's like the best godfather you could possibly have.
我认为很明显，约翰逊喜欢的不仅仅是家庭舒适。他还喜欢那种家庭感，因为他自己没有孩子，而思拉尔夫人有成百上千个孩子。事实上，约翰逊似乎比思拉尔夫人自己更能与思拉尔夫人庞大的孩子群相处。所以她有点反复无常的爱。她可能会突然，你知道，用吻淹没一个孩子。但我认为大多数时候她觉得她的孩子很无聊。相比之下，约翰逊认为他们很棒。我是说，他就像你能拥有的最好的教父。
You know, he'll kind of crawl around on his hands and knees. He'll allow them to clamber over him. So Bate wonderfully describes the Thrail Children. They viewed him as a combination of friend and a sort of toy elephant. I love that. Johnson's favourite among the Thrail Children is the eldest, who is also called Hester after her mother. And Johnson nicknames her Queen Esther. So Esther is the biblical heroine who marries the king of Persia. And so in that way, she comes to be nicknamed Queenie.
你知道，他会四肢着地爬来爬去。他会允许他们爬到他身上。所以贝特精彩地描述了思拉尔的孩子们。他们把他看作是朋友和某种玩具大象的结合体。我喜欢这个。约翰逊在思拉尔孩子中最喜欢的是长女，她也叫海丝特，随她母亲。约翰逊给她起了个绰号叫“以斯帖女王”。所以以斯帖是嫁给波斯国王的圣经女英雄。就这样，她被昵称为“奎妮”。
And Johnson's birthday is one day after Queenie's. And so they always share a birthday party. So there's Johnson in his party hat and there's Queenie in her party hat. That's fun. Yeah, it's fun and affecting. But there's one person who's not so keen on this. And this is somebody else who feels a bit possessive about Johnson. And this, of course, is Boswell.
约翰逊的生日比奎妮晚一天。所以他们总是分享一个生日派对。所以约翰逊戴着派对帽，奎妮也戴着派对帽。那很有趣。是的，这很有趣且感人。但有一个人不太喜欢这样。这就是另一个对约翰逊感到有点占有欲的人。这当然就是博斯韦尔。
Because Boswell has always thought of himself as the number one Johnson superfan. Yes. And suddenly he's got to share Johnson with all these other people who, you know, maybe they're ticking other boxes. I mean, Boswell's not going to climb over him and like wear party hats, is he? No. No. And I think because Boswell is basically stuck up in Scotland a lot of the time, it does take him time to realise just what a rival for, you know, his, his hero's affections he has in Mrs. Thrail. We talked in our second episode about this great Shakespeare jamboree that David Garrick, Johnson's old friend and the most famous actor of his day, that he stages in
因为博斯韦尔一直认为自己是约翰逊的头号超级粉丝。是的。突然间，他不得不与所有这些其他人分享约翰逊，你知道，也许他们正在满足其他需求。我是说，博斯韦尔不会爬到他身上，也不会戴派对帽，对吧？不。不。而且我认为因为博斯韦尔基本上大部分时间都被困在苏格兰，他确实需要时间来意识到他在思拉尔夫人那里拥有一个多么强大的竞争对手，来争夺他英雄的爱。我们在第二集里谈到了大卫·加里克，约翰逊的老朋友和当时最著名的演员，在1769年于斯特拉特福举办的那场盛大的莎士比亚庆典。当博斯韦尔去那里时，他惊讶地发现约翰逊不在那里，因为加里克是约翰逊的老朋友，而且约翰逊也是当时最著名的莎士比亚学者。他四年前发表了那篇非常著名的《莎士比亚序言》。所以博斯韦尔完全认为他会出现在那里。他说，嗯，约翰逊在哪里？是的。他发现约翰逊和思拉尔夫妇去布莱顿度假了。他每天都在游泳。如果他不游泳，他就和思拉尔先生一起去打猎。
Stratford in 1769. And when Boswell goes there, he's amazed to find that Johnson isn't there because Garack is Johnson's old friend, but also Johnson is the most famous Shakespearean scholar of his day. He'd published this very famous preface to Shakespeare four years previously. And so Boswell had completely taken for granted that he'd be there. And he says, well, where is Johnson? Yeah. He discovers that Johnson has gone to Brighton on holiday with the thrales. Every day he's going swimming. And if he's not swimming, he's going hunting with Mr. Thrail.
而且思拉尔先生骑着马跑了50英里。约翰逊决心证明他也能做到这一点。他并不真正喜欢打猎。但他也在四处奔波。有一次他们出去骑了很长时间的马。思拉尔先生决心证明他，你知道，他不知疲倦。于是他跳过了一个凳子。然后约翰逊也跳过了一个凳子。
And Mr. Thrail is kind of galloping around for 50 miles. Johnson is determined to show that he can do this as well. He doesn't really like hunting. But he's galloping around as well. And there's one occasion they go out for an incredibly long ride. And Mr. Thrail is determined to show that he, you know, he's untired. And so he jumps over a stool. And Johnson then jumps over a stool.
他不是一个应该跳过凳子的人。但他还是成功了。所以对于博斯韦尔来说，博斯韦尔大概认为，你知道，我了解约翰逊。我拥有约翰逊。我理解约翰逊。他失去了理智，正和他的新朋友混在一起。他不是他自己了。游泳、打猎、跳过凳子。
And he's not a man who should be jumping over a stool. But he kind of gets away with it. So for Boswell, Boswell presumably thinks, you know, I know Johnson. I own Johnson. I understand Johnson. He's lost the plot and he's hanging around with his new friends. He's not himself. Swimming, hunting, jumping over stool.
所以到底发生了什么？是的。这就像你遇到某人，汤姆，然后去伊比沙岛泡吧什么的。而不和我一起做播客。是的，或者我在想另一个类比。你会做什么会完全，我告诉你是什么，如果你开始玩电子游戏。
So what the hell's going on? Yeah. It's as though you were to meet somebody, Tom, and go off clubbing in Ibitha or something. and not doing podcasts with you. Yeah, or I'm trying to think of another analogy. What would you do that would be totally, I tell you what is, it's if you took up video games.
你不再叫它们电脑游戏，而叫它们电子游戏。是的，我的新朋友。是的，和你的新朋友。如果你说，哦，我最近经常玩 FIFA，我会说，什么，发生了什么事？是的，我认为这就是正在发生的事情。而博斯韦尔现在已经意识到
You stopped calling them computer games and you called them video games. Yeah, my new friend. Yeah, with your new friend. If you were like, oh, I'm playing loads of FIFA these days, I'd be like, what, what's going on? Yeah, I think that is what's going on. And the fact that Boswell has now realised
约翰逊宁愿在布莱顿游泳也不愿参加斯特拉特福的莎士比亚节，这完全让他看清了思拉尔夫人对约翰逊的掌控。所以他觉得，嗯，我没有，你知道，我需要把坏事变好。我显然不能真的把他们分开。而思拉尔夫人，给她点赞，我是说，她相当宽宏大量。你知道，她现在已经把自己定位为新的头号超级粉丝，但她对博斯韦尔非常好。她没有，你知道，因为他被稍微取代了而让他难堪。所以她经常邀请博斯韦尔去斯特里汉姆庄园，有时甚至在约翰逊不在的时候。有一次，当
that Johnson would rather go swimming in Brighton than attend a Shakespeare Festival in Stratford kind of completely opens his eyes to Mrs. Thrail's hold on Johnson. And so he feels, well, I haven't, you know, I need to make the best of a bad job. I clearly can't really prize them apart. And Mrs. Thrail, to give her credit, I mean, she's pretty magnanimous. You know, she's installed herself now as the new number one superfan, but she's very kind to Boswell. She doesn't kind of rub his nose in the fact that he's been slightly replaced. So she's regularly inviting Boswell to straighten place, sometimes not even when Johnson's there. And on one occasion when the
他们三个人一起吃早餐时，她俯身在他耳边低语，有许多人钦佩和尊重约翰逊先生，但你和我爱他。当然，博斯韦尔记录了这一点。是的。所以这证明了，你知道，他很高兴，很高兴被告知这一点，我想。所以回到博斯韦尔身上，思拉尔夫人对约翰逊去苏格兰起了推动作用，不是吗？她对约翰逊说，你应该和博斯韦尔一起去旅行。她真是太宽宏大量了。这确实很宽宏大量。这也有一点奇怪。所以他在1773年夏天写了那封信。也就是在他离开去爱丁堡和博斯韦尔环游高地和赫布里底群岛的前几周。他此时又非常痛苦。这部分是因为
three of them are having breakfast together, she leans forward and whispers in his ear, there are many who admire and respect Mr. Johnson, but you and I love him. And of course, Boswell records this. Yeah. And so it's proof that, you know, he's happy, happy to be told this, I think. So to go to stick on Boswell for a second, Mrs. Thrail is instrumental in Johnson going to Scotland, isn't she? She says to Johnson, you should go on this trip with Boswell. That's very magnanimous of her. It is magnanimous. It's also a little bit weird. So he wrote that letter in the summer of 1773. So a few weeks before he leaves for Edinburgh and his tour with Boswell around the Highlands and the Hebrides. He is very miserable again at this point. This is partly
他眼睛感染得很严重。但这也是因为他觉得被思拉尔夫人忽视了。思拉尔夫人忽视他并不是不合理的，因为她的母亲快要去世了。她的丈夫进行了一项轻率的投资。所以思拉尔夫人正在竭尽全力试图阻止酿酒厂破产，她非常成功地做到了这一点。所以酿酒厂最终没问题。而且，当然，她还有成群的孩子要照顾。所以她感到非常忙乱。她没有时间给约翰逊她通常给予的关注。所以约翰逊发现自己被忽视了，正如他所见，写了你引用的那封信。这部分是一种责备，我想。你知道，这就像一个孩子觉得被母亲忽视了一样。但这也是一个请求，请求确认他没有碍事。
because he's got a bad eye infection. But it's also because he feels himself neglected by Mrs. Thrail. And it's not unreasonable for Mrs. Thrail to be neglecting him because her mother is dying. Her husband has made an imprudent investment. And so Mrs. Thrail is pulling every string she can to try and stave off the bankruptcy of the brewery, which she is very successful in doing. So the brewery actually turns out to be fine. And also, of course, she's got all these multitudes of children to look after. So she feels very harried. She doesn't have time to give Johnson the attention. that she normally does. And so Johnson, finding himself neglected as he sees it, writes this letter that you quoted. And it's partly a reproach, I think. You know, it's like a kind of almost like a child feeling neglected by his mother. But it's also a request for a reassurance that he is not in her way.
你知道，如果她不想要他，那么，你知道，他就会走。思拉尔夫人回复了，我能向我亲爱的约翰逊先生承诺什么我还没有采取的照顾呢？他还没有经历过什么温柔呢？她说，你为什么不去赫布里底群岛？我相信博斯韦尔先生会是你最好的医生。我是说，这非常明智。去度假吧。去，你知道，骑马环游高地，什么的。和博斯韦尔待在一起。然后她，我说过那封信里有一种孩子拽着母亲裙子的感觉。也许我应该说把思拉尔夫人描述为他的女家庭教师，因为她就是这样描述自己的。
You know, and if she doesn't want him, then, you know, he will go. And Mrs. Thrail replies to it, what care can I promise my dear Mr. Johnson that I have not already taken? What tenderness that he has not already experienced. And she says, why don't you go to the Hebrides? I believe Mr. Boswell will be your best physician. I mean, it's very sensible. Go and have a holiday. Go and, you know, ride a horse around the highlands, whatever. Spend time with Boswell. And she then, I said that there's something of a kind of a child tugging on the skirts of his mother about that letter. Maybe I should say describing Mrs. Strel as his governess, because that is how she describes herself.
所以她写信给约翰逊，当他即将离开去苏格兰时，再见，要乖，不要因为你的女家庭教师没有用足够的鞭子而和她吵架。所以她让他去旅行了，正如他们所说，他去了苏格兰。在那次旅程中，他和博斯韦尔当然变得非常亲密，尽管他们偶尔会吵架，不是吗？博斯韦尔一直在记录约翰逊的谈话。
So she writes to Johnson, as he's about to leave for Scotland, farewell and be good, and do not quarrel with your governess for not using the rod enough. So she sent him on his travels, as it were, and he's gone off to Scotland. and over the course of that journey he and Boswell, of course, have become very close, although they have had the odd row, haven't they? And Boswell has been writing Dan Johnson's conversation.
这就是博斯韦尔正在构思那部伟大传记的时刻，当然。你知道，那在他的脑海中正在成形，不是吗？是的，我想他已经，你知道，在那之前就已经计划这样做了。但他想和约翰逊一起去旅行的原因之一是，这给了他一个机会，不仅可以记录谈话，还可以问约翰逊关于他遇到博斯韦尔之前的生活细节。所以这也是博斯韦尔正在做的事情。但随后博斯韦尔在约翰逊回到伦敦时失去了控制。思拉尔夫人又回到了驾驶座上，正如他们所说。是的。当然，博斯韦尔现在担心，实际上也许
And this is the point, of course, at which Boswell is formulating the great biography. You know, that's taking shape in his mind, isn't it? Yeah, I think he's already, you know, he's been planning to do it before that. But one of the reasons that he's wanted to go on this trip with Johnson is it gives him a chance, not just to record conversation, but also to ask Johnson, details about his life before he met Boswell. And so that's also what Boswell is doing. But then Boswell loses control when Johnson goes back to London. Mrs Thrail is back in the driver's seat, as it were. Yeah. And of course, Boswell is now worrying that actually perhaps
思拉尔夫人比他更有能力写出这部伟大的传记。第二年，当约翰逊和思拉尔夫妇一起去旅行时，不是去苏格兰，而是去威尔士，他的心情并没有好转。你知道，思拉尔夫人的故乡，约翰逊试图安慰他。威尔士与英格兰几乎没有什么不同，它对旅行者的推测没有任何贡献。这对我们的威尔士听众来说是需要记住的。
Mrs. Thrail is better placed to write this great biography than he is. And his mood is not improved the following year when Johnson goes with the Thrails on a tour, not of Scotland, but of Wales. You know, Mrs. Rail's native land, and Johnson tries to reassure him. Wales is so little different from England that it offers nothing to the speculation of the traveller. That's something for our Welsh listeners to bear in mind.
必须说博斯韦尔并不完全相信这一点，所以他仍然感到焦虑，坦率地说，还有点嫉妒。不敢相信约翰逊竟然那样贬低威尔士。可怜。嗯，他还和他们一起去了巴黎，对巴黎也同样不客气。我想是为了让博斯韦尔振作起来。基本上在接下来的六年里，
It has to be said Boswell doesn't entirely believe this, and so he remains anxious and, frankly, a little bit jealous. Can't believe Johnson is dissing Wales in that way. Poor. Well, he also goes with them to Paris, and is similarly disobliting about Paris. I think to try and cheer Boswell up. And basically for the next six years,
约翰逊一直待在思拉尔夫人家，他经常在斯特里汉姆庄园，而且他显然非常忠于思拉尔夫人，以至于博斯韦尔在后来写那部伟大传记时，几乎不忍心提及它。所以你可以读博斯韦尔的传记，几乎不知道他在这几年里大部分时间都和思拉尔夫妇在一起。
Johnson remains at Mrs. Thrales, and he is so often at Streatham Place, and he's so patently devoted to Mrs. Thrail that Boswell, when in due course he comes to write his great biography, barely bring himself to mention it. So you could read Boswell's biography and barely be aware that he'd been spending most of his time in these years with the Thrails.
但一切都变了，不是吗？1781年4月。1781年，亨利·思拉尔，反正他从不说话，所以谁会注意到呢？他中风了，卒中，这就是他的结局。他死了。这就是他的结局。博斯韦尔做了一件非常奇怪的事情。他写了一首诗，在诗中他想象约翰逊，基本上处于一种色情狂喜的状态，他终于可以和思拉尔夫人结婚了，带着对强烈的春药痉挛的喜悦。我们整晚都要回报。那太疯狂了。博斯韦尔在写约翰逊的色情作品。他对此非常满意，以至于他到处走，他去了伦敦，到处给所有的朋友朗读。
But everything changes, doesn't it? In 1781, April. 1781, Henry Thrail, who never speaks anyway, so how does anyone notice? He has a massive stroke, apoplexy, and that's the end of him. He's dead. That is the end of him. And Boswell does a very weird thing. He writes a poem in which he imagines Johnson, basically in a state of erotic ecstasy, that he can finally marry Mrs. Thrail with delight in the keen Aphrodisium spasm. shall we reciprocate all night. That's mad. Boswell is writing Johnson erotica. And he's so pleased with it that he goes around, he's down to London and goes around reading it out to all his friends.
那里发生了一些非常奇怪的事情。这太奇怪了。现实情况再不同不过了，因为约翰逊，现在思拉尔先生死了，真的很担心未来会怎样。所以他再次不断写信给思拉尔夫人寻求安慰。不要忽视我，也不要放弃我。没有人会比我更爱你或尊重你。但这一次，思拉尔夫人没有回信说，别担心，我会永远在那里支持你。因为她在想，嗯，我不再有这个沉默寡言、风流成性的丈夫了。这意味着我，你知道，我可以找个新人。我可以找个好得多的人。
There's something very weird going on there. It's so odd. The reality couldn't be more different because Johnson, now that Mr Thrail is dead, is really worried what the future is going to hold. And so again, he keeps writing to Mrs. Thrail for reassurance. Do not neglect me, nor relinquish me. Nobody will ever love or honor you more. But this time, Mrs. Thrail doesn't write back and say, they're there, I'll always be there for you. Because she is thinking, well, I've, I no longer have this taciturn, philandering husband. That means that I'm, you know, I could find someone new. I could find someone much better.
比约翰逊还好？嗯，我是说，约翰逊现在已经71岁了。思拉尔夫人多大？所以她现在一定40出头，30多岁末，40出头。约翰逊，你知道，他仍然有他的痉挛抽动。他仍然要求她陪他喝茶喝到很晚。口袋里装满了橘子皮。而且他显然也变得相当臭了。哦，哇。所以所有这些都是在思拉尔先生死后，约翰逊和思拉尔夫人之间开始产生某种距离的原因。在1782年秋天，也就是思拉尔死后一年，
Better even than Johnson? Well, I mean, Johnson by now is 71 years old. How old is Mrs. Thrail? So she must be in her early 40s now, late 30s, early. 40s. Johnson, you know, he's still got his spasmodic twitches. He's still demanding that she stay up late with him drinking tea. Pockets full of orange peel. And he's apparently also becoming quite smelly. Oh, wow. So all of these are reasons why that a certain distance starts to open up between Johnson and Mrs. Thrail in the wake of Mr. Thraill's death. And in the autumn of 1782, so that's a year after
思拉尔夫人把斯特里汉姆庄园租出去了。约翰逊显然很清楚，你知道，他不会再回到那里了。所以他非常心烦意乱。在永远离开斯特里汉姆庄园前不久，他坐在斯特里汉姆那个华丽的小村庄里那座美丽的小教堂里。他为思拉尔一家祈祷，主啊，我将这个家庭托付给您父亲般的保护。保佑、引导并捍卫他们。但我恐怕仁慈的主并没有保佑、引导并捍卫他们。因为思拉尔夫人已经坠入爱河，而且不是和约翰逊，而是和她孩子们的音乐老师，一个非常英俊的意大利年轻人，叫加布里埃尔·皮亚齐，当然我们提到过思拉尔夫人会说
Thrails death, Mrs. Thrail rents Streatham place out. And it's obviously, obvious to Johnson that, you know, he's not going to be going back there. And so he's incredibly distraught. And shortly before leaving Streatham Place forever, he sits in the beautiful little church in the gorgeous little village of Streatham. And he prays for the thrales, to thy fatherly protection, O Lord, I commend this family. Bless, guide and defend them. But the good Lord, I'm afraid, does not bless guide and defend them. Because Mrs. Thrail has fallen spectacularly. in love and it's not with Johnson but with her children's music teacher who's a very handsome young Italian called Gabrielle Piazzi and of course we mentioned that Mrs. Thrail speaks
意大利语，所以你知道，这对他们来说看起来不错，但基本上对其他人来说看起来不太好。是的，所以皮亚齐在思拉尔夫人的朋友或她的孩子中不太受欢迎，是吗？是的，你认为皮亚齐是个淘金者或一般意义上的坏人吗？我认为这就是她朋友们的想法。正如我们将看到的，这也是媒体的想法，我认为这也是奎妮特别的想法，她现在18岁了。海丝特，是的。是的，海丝特。她非常令人生畏。她领导了反对她母亲恋情的行动。有一段时间她成功地拆散了它，她让皮亚齐离开英国回到意大利。但思拉尔夫人随后陷入了一种非常招摇的衰落，说如果皮亚齐不回来她就会死。
Italian so you know it's it's looking good for them but it's not looking good basically for anyone else yeah so Piazzi is not terribly popular is he with Mrs Thrail's friends or her children yeah do you think Piotse is a bit of a gold digger or a bad sort generally I think that is what her friends think. It's also, as we will see, what the press think, and I think it's also what Queenie in particular thinks, who by now is 18. Hester, yeah. Yes, Hester. She's very formidable. And she leads the opposition to her mother's affair. And for a while she succeeds in breaking it up, and she gets Piazzi to leave England and go back to Italy. But Mrs. Thrail then goes into a very ostentatious decline, says that she's going to die unless Piaz comes back.
所以皮亚齐确实回来了。于是1784年7月25日，海丝特·思拉尔夫人，那位非常受人尊敬的酿酒商思拉尔先生的前妻，变成了海丝特·皮亚齐夫人，一位意大利音乐老师的妻子。现在的反应是恶毒的。
so Piazzi does return. And so on the 25th of July 1784, Mrs. Hester Thrail, the former wife of the very respectable brewer, Mr. Thrail, becomes Mrs. Hester Piazzi, the wife of an Italian music teacher. And the reaction now is vituperative
所以皮亚齐确实回来了。于是，在1784年7月25日，海丝特·思雷尔夫人，这位受人尊敬的酿酒商思雷尔先生的前妻，成为了海丝特·皮亚齐夫人，嫁给了一位意大利音乐老师。而此时的反应是恶毒的谩骂。
because it is open to the world. So I said that the press were negative. They write editorials, fulminating against Mrs. Piazzi, because by raising an obscure and penniless fiddler into sudden wealth. She has brought disgrace on her family, on Britain. On Wales, most importantly. Absolutely shocker. And Mrs. Piazzi's daughters agree. And they come to believe that their mother had made her second marriage, and I quote from one of them, from original and
因为它是向世界开放的。所以我说媒体是负面的。他们写社论，猛烈抨击皮亚齐夫人，因为她把一个默默无闻、身无分文的提琴手捧成了暴发户。她给她的家庭、给英国蒙羞。最重要的是，给威尔士蒙羞。简直令人震惊。皮亚齐夫人的女儿们也同意这一点。她们开始相信，她们的母亲进行第二次婚姻——我引用其中一位女儿的话——是出于对我们所有人的原始而顽固的厌恶，以及出于她对她父亲的仇恨。所以她们真的无法接受。
persevering dislike and real hatred of us all and from her hatred of her father. So they're really not taking it well. And Mrs. Piazzi responds to this by condemning her daughters as savage and ungrateful and nicknaming them Reagan and gonoril after the monstrous daughters in King Lear. And essentially, the whole family breaks up and Queenie never forgives her. She ends up interestingly marrying Lord Keith, who featured in our series on Lord Nelson. He had very sound views on Emma Hamilton. Yeah, he clearly doesn't approve of headstrong marriages. I think it's fair to say.
而皮亚齐夫人对此的回应是谴责她的女儿们野蛮且忘恩负义，并以《李尔王》中那两个残忍的女儿的名字，称她们为里根和高纳里尔。本质上，整个家庭分崩离析，奎妮从未原谅她。有趣的是，她最终嫁给了基思勋爵，他曾在我们关于纳尔逊勋爵的系列节目中出现过。他对艾玛·汉密尔顿有非常中肯的看法。是的，很明显他不赞成这种任性的婚姻。我认为这样说很公平。
But crucially, what does Johnson make of all this? because he is he, surely he's gutted, that Mrs. Thraele has become Mrs. Piotse. He's completely devastated. So right up to the end, he is hoping that it won't happen. And then Mrs. Thraeller, she still is at this point, writes him a letter saying, look, I'm going to be tying the knot with Signor Piazzi. And Johnson's so devastated that he writes her a very, an uncharacteristically cruel response. If you have abandoned your children and your religion, God forgive your wickedness.
但关键是，约翰逊对此有何感想？因为他就是他，他肯定很痛苦，因为思雷尔夫人变成了皮亚齐夫人。他彻底崩溃了。所以直到最后，他都希望这件事不会发生。然后思雷尔夫人——她当时还是这个名字——写信给他，说，看，我要和皮亚齐先生结婚了。约翰逊非常痛苦，以至于他写了一封非常、非常不寻常的残酷回信。如果你抛弃了你的孩子和你的宗教，愿上帝宽恕你的邪恶。
And the moment he sent it, he's. kind of repenting it and he writes her a second letter kind of retracting these angry words, but it's too late, their friendship is over. They will never see each other again. And by now, Samuel Johnson is 75 years old. He is in palpable physical decline. He's had a stroke a few months earlier. And he's bereft of this family with which he had been so intimate for 15 very happy years. And so he's never felt so alone. So heartbroken, Samuel Johnson, is alone or is he? Because after the break, we will be digging into the extraordinary story of Samuel Johnson's secret son.
在他寄出这封信的那一刻，他有点后悔了，于是他写了第二封信，试图收回这些愤怒的话，但为时已晚，他们的友谊结束了。他们再也不会见面了。此时，塞缪尔·约翰逊已经75岁了。他的身体状况明显在衰退。几个月前他中风了。他失去了这个他与之亲密相处了15年幸福时光的家庭。所以他从未感到如此孤独。塞缪尔·约翰逊如此心碎，他是孤独的吗？因为休息之后，我们将深入挖掘塞缪尔·约翰逊私生子的非凡故事。
Okay, welcome back to the rest is history. What a cliffhanger. We left Samuel Johnson in the shadow of his rupture with the former Mrs. Thrail, who's now disgraced herself and let whales down by becoming Mrs. Piazzi. So there'll be no more trips to the paradise of Streatham. But I tantalise you, dear listeners, with the talk of Samuel Johnson's secret son. And we'll be getting into that, won't we, Tom? But first of all, you know,
好的，欢迎回到《历史的其余部分》。真是个悬念。我们把塞缪尔·约翰逊留在了他与前思雷尔夫人决裂的阴影中，她现在已经蒙羞，并因成为皮亚齐夫人而让威尔士失望了。所以再也不会有去斯特里汉姆天堂的旅行了。但我用塞缪尔·约翰逊私生子的传闻吊了你们的胃口，亲爱的听众们。我们会深入探讨这个话题，对吧，汤姆？但首先，你知道，
there's always been this tension with Johnson. There's the clubbable side, the sociable side, the Johnson who surrounds himself with Garrick and Burke and Joshua Reynolds and Boswell. And then there's the sort of melancholy solitary man who's bottling up his mental health anguish. and not subscribing to Betelb and talking to Prince Harry. So where is he now?
约翰逊身上一直存在这种张力。有一面是善于交际的，社交的一面，那个被加里克、伯克、约书亚·雷诺兹和鲍斯韦尔环绕的约翰逊。然后是那种忧郁孤独的人，他压抑着自己的心理痛苦，不订阅《贝特尔布》，也不和哈里王子交谈。那么他现在在哪里？
He's 75. You said he's developed a terrible stench. But is he... Yeah. Is he... I don't think it's a terrible stench. I think it's just maybe palpable if you've been tipped off. It's mildly off-putting.
他75岁了。你说他身上有一种可怕的恶臭。但他是……是的。他是……我不认为那是可怕的恶臭。我想如果有人提醒你，那可能只是明显的。这有点令人反感。
Well, the thing is, it's not sufficiently off-putting that his friends don't want to see him. He remains this. word clubbable, which is a word that Johnson has coined. He originally used it to describe Boswell as it happens. And even though he's been staying with the thrales all these past years, he has continued to see all his friends. I mean, they are still very much part of his social circuit. And even if he's in his kind of, you know, his rooms off Fleet Street, a bulk court he's now moved to, which is very near Goff Square, which you can still go and visit to this day, he's not alone there either. Listeners may remember it in the very first episode.
嗯，问题是，这还不足以让他的朋友们不想见他。他仍然保持着“善于交际”这个词，这是约翰逊自己创造的词。碰巧的是，他最初用这个词来形容鲍斯韦尔。尽管过去这些年他一直和思雷尔一家住在一起，但他一直都在见他所有的朋友。我的意思是，他们仍然是他社交圈的重要组成部分。即使他住在弗利特街附近的房间里，他现在搬到了博尔特法院，离戈夫广场很近，你今天仍然可以去参观，他在那里也不孤单。听众们可能在第一集中记得，
we had our first mention of Mrs. Thrail, and I quoted her as saying about Johnson, that he loved the poor as I never saw anyone else do. And what makes us say this was the memory of all the waifs and strays that he was always giving shelter to in his rooms. So to quote her, she wrote how for years he'd nursed whole nests of people in his house where the lame, the blind, the sick and the sorrowful found a sure retreat from all the evils whence his little income could secure them. he also has with him this man who is nominally his man-servant but had in effect come to rank as his son. So you were slightly, slightly over-emphasizing the element of scandal there. His secret son.
我们第一次提到了思雷尔夫人，我引用她的话说，约翰逊爱穷人，我从未见过其他人这样做。让我们这样说的原因是，他总是收留那些流浪儿和无家可归者在他房间里的记忆。所以引用她的话，她写道，多年来，他在家里照顾了整窝的人，瘸子、瞎子、病人和悲伤的人，从他微薄的收入所能确保的所有邪恶中找到了可靠的避难所。他身边还有这个人，名义上是他的男仆，但实际上已经排到了他儿子的位置。所以你稍微、稍微夸大了那里的丑闻成分。他的私生子。
His adoptive son. And apologies to listeners, you may feel cheated of that. And this is a guy called Francis Barber, Frank Barber. And he was a one-time slave and orphan who at the first. the age of 10 had been brought from Jamaica by his owner to England, where he'd been set free, and Frank Barber had ended up in Johnson's charge. And Johnson thought he was wonderful and essentially fathered him, paid for his schooling. Frank then went and signed up to the Royal Navy, which to Johnson was an absolutely mad thing to do.
他的养子。向听众道歉，你们可能会觉得被骗了。这是一个叫弗朗西斯·巴伯，弗兰克·巴伯的人。他曾经是一个奴隶和孤儿，在10岁时被他的主人从牙买加带到英国，在那里他获得了自由，弗兰克·巴伯最终归约翰逊照管。约翰逊认为他很棒，本质上像父亲一样抚养他，支付了他的学费。弗兰克后来去报名参加了皇家海军，这对约翰逊来说是一件绝对疯狂的事情。
Johnson thought that you were better off in prison than in the Royal Navy, because at least in prison you couldn't drown. And so Johnson pulls strings to get Frank out of the Navy. And Frank comes back and kind of operate kind of as Johnson's man-servant. But I mean, he's really his companion. And Johnson ends up writing Frank into his will as his residual air. And in due cause, when Johnson dies, Barber will inherit most of his, you know, the property that hasn't been given to other people. And he moves to Litchfield. So Johnson's native home, he uses the legacy to set up a draper. shop. He marries a local woman and I gather that his descendants live in Litchfield to this day. And Frank or Francis Barber, to be clear, you know, you said he was formerly a slave. He's, he's black. He's of African descent. Yes, he is. Johnson has always been an abolitionist, hasn't he? That's why he was down on the American tax rebels because he pointed out their hypocrisy in wittering on about liberty when they were some of the most terrible people who ever lived. Yes. So he essentially has an adoptive black son.
约翰逊认为在监狱里比在皇家海军里好，因为至少在监狱里你不会淹死。所以约翰逊动用关系把弗兰克从海军里弄了出来。弗兰克回来了，有点像约翰逊的男仆。但我的意思是，他真的是他的同伴。约翰逊最终把弗兰克写进了遗嘱，作为他的剩余遗产继承人。在适当的时候，当约翰逊去世时，巴伯将继承他大部分的财产，你知道，那些没有给其他人的财产。他搬到了利奇菲尔德。所以约翰逊的故乡，他用这笔遗产开了一家布料店。他娶了一位当地妇女，据我所知，他的后代至今仍住在利奇菲尔德。弗兰克或弗朗西斯·巴伯，说清楚，你知道，你说他曾经是奴隶。他是黑人。他是非洲裔。是的，他是。约翰逊一直是个废奴主义者，不是吗？这就是为什么他反对美国税务叛乱分子，因为他指出了他们的虚伪，当他们谈论自由时，他们却是历史上最可怕的人之一。是的。所以他本质上有一个黑人养子。
He also has another series of companions. One of the series of companions is probably the most famous of all the creatures who lived with Johnson in his rooms, human or non-human. And this companion was dead by 1784. But since he's the only one who has his own statue, I think it would be remiss not to mention him. And again, anyone who wants to see the statue, it's in Goff Square. It's a very handsome statue. and it's a statue of Hodge. And Hodge was one of a number of cats kept by Johnson.
他还有另一系列同伴。其中一系列同伴可能是所有与约翰逊住在一起的生物中最著名的一个，无论是人类还是非人类。这位同伴在1784年去世了。但既然他是唯一一个拥有自己雕像的同伴，我想如果不提他将是失职。同样，任何想看雕像的人，它就在戈夫广场。这是一座非常英俊的雕像，是霍奇的雕像。霍奇是约翰逊养的几只猫之一。
But the only one that we know by name, thanks to Boswell specifically mentioning him in his life of Johnson. And in fact, Boswell himself hated cats and had been criticized for it by Rousseau when Boswell had been to meet Rousseau. Rousseau thought cats were great. He said the cat is free and will never consent to become a slave. And I think Johnson probably agreed with that. it was maybe one of the few things that Johnson and Rousseau would actually have agreed on. Johnson adored cats and he adored Hodge and would go out to buy him oysters, as Boswell says,
但我们唯一知道名字的猫，多亏了鲍斯韦尔在《约翰逊传》中特别提到了他。事实上，鲍斯韦尔本人讨厌猫，并因此受到卢梭的批评，当时鲍斯韦尔去见了卢梭。卢梭认为猫很棒。他说猫是自由的，永远不会同意成为奴隶。我想约翰逊可能同意这一点。这可能是约翰逊和卢梭实际上会同意的少数几件事之一。约翰逊崇拜猫，他崇拜霍奇，会出去给他买牡蛎，正如鲍斯韦尔所说，
lest the servants having that trouble should take a dislike to the poor creature. The cat ate oysters? Do cats eat oysters? Yeah, clearly. I mean, oysters were much more common then than they are now. It was a kind of working class food rather than going to a posh restaurant. But even so, Johnson is obviously spoiling Hodge. There's this kind of very touching, sad story that Boswell narrates. It was a ludicrous account Boswell writes of the despicable state of a young gentleman of good family. Sir, Johnson says, when I heard of him last, he was
以免仆人们因为麻烦而对这个可怜的生物产生反感。猫吃牡蛎？猫吃牡蛎吗？是的，很明显。我的意思是，牡蛎在当时比现在普遍得多。这是一种工人阶级的食物，而不是去高档餐厅。但即便如此，约翰逊显然是在宠坏霍奇。鲍斯韦尔讲述了一个非常感人、悲伤的故事。鲍斯韦尔写道，这是一个关于一位出身名门的年轻绅士的可鄙状态的荒谬描述。先生，约翰逊说，当我最后一次听到他的消息时，他
running about town shooting cats. And then in a sort of kindly reverie, he bethought himself of his own favourite cat and said, but Hodge shan't be shot. No, no, Hodge shall not be shot. And you can imagine him kind of tickling Hodge under his chin. So what's happened to Hodge? Hodge is dead, is he? Are we killed off Hodge? Hodges long since died, but there's probably another cat, and we don't know, because Boswell doesn't like cats, so he doesn't keep us up to speed on that. So Mrs. Thrail is morally dead, because she's married an Italian fiddler. Hodg is physically dead. He's gone.
在城里跑来跑去射杀猫。然后，在一种亲切的遐想中，他想到了自己最喜欢的猫，说，但霍奇不该被射杀。不，不，霍奇不该被射杀。你可以想象他挠霍奇下巴的样子。那么霍奇怎么了？霍奇死了，是吗？我们把霍奇写死了吗？霍奇早就死了，但可能还有另一只猫，我们不知道，因为鲍斯韦尔不喜欢猫，所以他没有让我们了解最新情况。所以思雷尔夫人在道德上已经死了，因为她嫁给了一个意大利提琴手。霍奇在身体上已经死了。他走了。
But Boswell is very much alive. Yeah, he's still on the scene. And, of course, by the summer of 1784, he is the only one of those two great Jonsonians, Mrs. Thrail and Boswell himself, who is still left standing. Now, there are times when even Johnson has grown impatient with Boswell's adulation. So at one point he brilliantly said, you have but two topics yourself and me, and I'm sick of both. But he knows that he is loved and revered by Boswell. And obviously, in the wake of the implosion of his relationship with Mrs. Thrail, this counts for a great deal. And so that summer of 1784, Johnson arrives in London on the 5th of May, and he spends two months there.
但鲍斯韦尔还活着。是的，他还在现场。当然，到1784年夏天，他是那两位伟大的约翰逊主义者——思雷尔夫人和鲍斯韦尔本人——中唯一还站着的人。现在，有时即使是约翰逊也对鲍斯韦尔的奉承感到不耐烦。所以有一次他精彩地说，你只有两个话题，你自己和我，而我对两者都感到厌倦。但他知道他被鲍斯韦尔爱戴和崇敬。显然，在他与思雷尔夫人的关系破裂之后，这意义重大。所以1784年那个夏天，约翰逊于5月5日抵达伦敦，他在那里待了两个月。
And most of his time is spent with Johnson. I think Boswell has a sense that this might be the last time that he will see Johnson. And the highlight of his stay is a trip to Oxford. And going to Oxford is a jaunt that has become something of a tradition when Boswell is down in London with Johnson. And actually those trips to Oxford had provided Boswell with some great moments which he records in his life. So there were times when Johnson had really shocked him. So you mentioned how Johnson is a very keen abolitionist. And so Boswell records an occasion when in company with some very grave men at Oxford,
他大部分时间都和约翰逊在一起。我想鲍斯韦尔有一种感觉，这可能是他最后一次见到约翰逊。他逗留期间的亮点是去牛津。去牛津是一次郊游，当鲍斯韦尔和约翰逊在伦敦时，这已经成为一种传统。事实上，那些去牛津的旅行为鲍斯韦尔提供了一些伟大的时刻，他记录在自己的传记中。所以有几次约翰逊真的让他感到震惊。所以你提到了约翰逊是一个非常热心的废奴主义者。所以鲍斯韦尔记录了一个场合，在牛津与一些非常严肃的人在一起时，
his toast was, here's to the next insurrection of the Negroes in the West Indies. So he's saying, here's to the next slave rebellion. And Boswell is shocked because he is completely unbothered by slavery and sees Johnson's opposition to it as what he describes as a mere violent prejudice against our West Indian and American settlers. So he thinks that Johnson's abolitionism is basically a little bit of a veneer that Johnson is pretending to be woke, but in reality he's just anti-American. I think that is probably what he's saying, because one of the reasons that Johnson is against the American Revolution, as we mentioned in our first episode, is that he sees the American Revolutionaries as hypocrites. Conversely, Boswell is all in favor of the American Revolution.
他的祝酒词是，为西印度群岛下一次黑人起义干杯。所以他说，为下一次奴隶起义干杯。鲍斯韦尔感到震惊，因为他完全不受奴隶制的影响，并将约翰逊对奴隶制的反对视为他所描述的“对我们西印度群岛和美国定居者的一种纯粹的暴力偏见”。所以他认为约翰逊的废奴主义基本上是一层薄薄的伪装，约翰逊只是在假装觉醒，但实际上他只是反美。我想这可能就是他所说的，因为正如我们在第一集中提到的，约翰逊反对美国革命的原因之一是，他认为美国革命者是伪君子。相反，鲍斯韦尔完全支持美国革命。
You know, he sees the Americans as being like the Corsicans and George Washington as being a kind of new Pauley. So that's something that they definitely disagree on. But it's not, you know, when they go to Oxford, it's not all kind of arguments about politics or whatever. So it's a perfect opportunity for Boswell to do some research to find out about Johnson's early years and to meet people who had known Johnson while he was a student. So in 1778, there's a famous incident. Johnson meets with a guy called Oliver Edwards, an old fellow collegian of Johnson's. Johnson hadn't seen this guy since 1729. And Johnson, of course, is famous.
你知道，他认为美国人就像科西嘉人，乔治·华盛顿就像一种新的保利。所以这是他们绝对不同意的事情。但是，你知道，当他们去牛津时，并不全是关于政治之类的争论。所以这对鲍斯韦尔来说是一个绝佳的机会，可以做一些研究，了解约翰逊的早年生活，并结识那些在约翰逊还是学生时就认识他的人。所以1778年，发生了一件著名的事件。约翰逊遇到了一个叫奥利弗·爱德华兹的人，他是约翰逊的老同学。约翰逊自1729年以来就没见过这个人。当然，约翰逊很有名。
So this guy, Edwards, comes up to him and says, oh, brilliant to see you. Johnson has no idea who he is. And then suddenly he remembers and they have this kind of great conversation. And Edwards reveals that he'd been, he'd practices a solicitor. He'd then retired to the country. Boswell describes him as a decent looking elderly man in gray clothes and a wig of many clothes. And it's evident that Edwards is a really charming man. So he has this very famous comment, you are a philosopher, Dr. Johnson.
所以这个叫爱德华兹的人走过来对他说，哦，见到你真是太棒了。约翰逊根本不知道他是谁。然后突然他想起来了，他们进行了这种很棒的谈话。爱德华兹透露他曾是一名律师。他后来退休到乡下。鲍斯韦尔形容他是一位穿着灰色衣服、戴着多层假发、看起来很体面的老年人。很明显，爱德华兹是一个非常有魅力的人。所以他有这句非常著名的评论，你是一位哲学家，约翰逊博士。
I have tried too in my time to be a philosopher, but I don't know how cheerfulness was always breaking in. This was one of the favourite quotations of Leonard Cohen. Hold on. When was cheerfulness breaking in with Leonard Cohen? Surely the answer, never. Also, he misattributed it to Ben Johnson, the Jacobian playwright. Oh, for God's sake.
我也曾在我的时代尝试成为一名哲学家，但我不知道为什么，快乐总是会闯进来。这是莱昂纳德·科恩最喜欢的引语之一。等等。莱昂纳德·科恩什么时候快乐闯进来了？当然答案是，从来没有。而且，他还把它错误地归因于雅各宾派剧作家本·约翰逊。哦，看在上帝的份上。
You know who doesn't like Donald Cohen? Who? Our producer, Tabby. She says in the chat, he's such a moaner. He's such a moaner. Well, I tell you someone who isn't a mona, even though he's very depressed, is by this point, Johnson. He is pretty down at this point. But he remains as fluent as ever.
你知道谁不喜欢唐纳德·科恩吗？谁？我们的制片人塔比。她在聊天中说，他真是个爱抱怨的人。他真是个爱抱怨的人。好吧，我告诉你一个不是爱抱怨的人，尽管他非常沮丧，那就是此时的约翰逊。他此时相当低落。但他依然像往常一样流利。
So on the carriage going up to Oxford in 1784, they meet with two American ladies, and they hear him talking. And my, my, how he does talk. Every sentence is an essay. And Johnson is polite to these ladies. I mean, they're Americans, so does he not incredibly rude to them in some way? I think actually they have, they're going to Worcester. And I think they have Worcestershire accents. Oh, really?
所以1784年去牛津的马车上，他们遇到了两位美国女士，她们听他说话。天哪，他说话的方式。每一句话都是一篇散文。约翰逊对这些女士很有礼貌。我的意思是，她们是美国人，所以他没有以某种方式对她们极其粗鲁吗？我想实际上她们要去伍斯特。我想她们有伍斯特郡的口音。哦，真的吗？
So I think maybe he doesn't appreciate that. But having said that, Johnson is clearly oppressed, not just by a sense of his own mortality, but by a sense of what may happen to him after his death. He has dinner with another old college friend of his, a guy called Dr. Adams, who'd been the master of Pembroke. And they start talking about death and what happens to people after death. And Johnson says, I am afraid I may be. one of those who shall be damned and Boswell in his stage direction says looking dismally. Dr. Adams, what do you mean by damned? Johnson, passionately and loudly, sent to hell, sir, and punished
所以我认为他可能没有意识到这一点。但话虽如此，约翰逊显然不仅被自己死亡的感觉所压迫，而且被他死后可能发生的事情所压迫。他和他的另一位老大学朋友，一位叫亚当斯博士的人共进晚餐，他曾是彭布罗克学院的院长。他们开始谈论死亡以及死后人们会发生什么。约翰逊说，我恐怕我可能是那些会被诅咒的人之一，鲍斯韦尔在他的舞台指导中说，表情凄凉。亚当斯博士，你说的诅咒是什么意思？约翰逊，充满激情且大声地，下地狱，先生，并受到
everlastingly. Is this because Johnson is troubled by things like his own lusts? They're always on his mind. He doesn't like to go and see the actresses because they'll excite his passions, all of that. Boswell certainly finds unsettling that Johnson is this nervous about the destination of his soul. And this is partly because Boswell's own faith is shaky. And so he needs Johnson to serve as an example of kind of unshakable Christian orthodoxy. And if Johnson is worried he's going to be damned, then, you know, what hell's going to happen to Boswell? And I think you're right that there may be a sexual dimension to this. Just like, what else has Johnson conceivably done that would get him into hell? I mean, he's not going to get in the hell
永恒的惩罚。这是因为约翰逊被他自己的欲望之类的事情困扰吗？它们总是出现在他的脑海里。他不喜欢去看女演员，因为她们会激发他的激情，所有这些。鲍斯韦尔当然觉得约翰逊对灵魂的归宿如此紧张令人不安。这部分是因为鲍斯韦尔自己的信仰是不稳固的。所以他需要约翰逊作为一种不可动摇的基督教正统的榜样。如果约翰逊担心他会被诅咒，那么，你知道，鲍斯韦尔会发生什么地狱般的事情？我认为你是对的，这可能有一个性的维度。就像，约翰逊还可能做了什么会让他下地狱的事情？我的意思是，他不会因为写了字典或对苏格兰人粗鲁而下地狱。但如果他脑子里有私人的事情在发生。这就像吉米·卡特在心里多次犯奸淫一样。你认为有那种情况吗？让我们一会儿再谈那个。让我们看看鲍斯韦尔和约翰逊的告别以及后来发生的事情。所以鲍斯韦尔于1784年7月1日离开伦敦。前一天晚上，他和约翰逊一起去约书亚·雷诺兹爵士那里吃了一顿私人晚餐。所以只有他们三个人。晚上结束时，雷诺兹把他的马车借给约翰逊，送他回弗利特街的博尔特法院。鲍斯韦尔和他一起去，扶约翰逊下马车，送他到从弗利特街通往博尔特法院的通道。鲍斯韦尔记得这次告别。当他
because he's written the dictionary or being rude about the Scots. But if there's private stuff that's going on in his head. It's like Jimmy Carter committing adultery in his heart many times. Do you think there's that? Let's come to that in a minute. Let's just look at Boswell and Johnson's parting and what happens then. So Boswell leaves London on the 1st July 1784. And the evening before, he had gone with Johnson to Sir Joshua Reynolds for a kind of private dinner. So just the three of them. And at the end of the evening, Reynolds lends Johnson his carriage to take him back to bulk court on Fleet Street. And Boswell goes with him and helps Johnson out of the carriage and sees him to the passageway which leads from Fleet Street to Bolt Court. Boswell remembered this parting. When he had
走下人行道时，他喊道再见，没有回头，带着一种凄凉的轻快感跳开了，我认为这是一个美妙的短语。约翰逊回到他的房间，在那里等着他的是思雷尔夫人那封致命的信，宣布她打算嫁给皮亚齐先生。所以所有那种噩梦现在都为约翰逊释放了。与此同时，鲍斯韦尔回到了苏格兰，他不断写信给约翰逊说，你知道，你怎么样？我非常担心你对你永恒灵魂的命运感到焦虑。告诉我这一切。约翰逊很愤怒。他不想谈论它。他不想忍受鲍斯韦尔的唠叨。所以他回信给鲍斯韦尔，经常写信给我，但要像个男人一样写。然后在11月3日，他做了一件他从不做的。他向鲍斯韦尔抱怨他的健康。他说，我感觉不舒服，我感到呼吸急促。我发现走路很困难。12月初，他起草了他的遗嘱。他烧掉了一些文件，也许是有暗示性的。他越来越频繁地祈祷。在12月13日的晚上，他去世了，第二天早上被发现死在床上。他的去世被标记为一个非常庄严的国家事件。
got down upon the foot pavement, he called out farewell and without looking back, sprung away with a kind of pathetic briskness, which I think is a wonderful phrase. Johnson goes back into his rooms and waiting for him there is the fatal letter from Mrs. Thrail announcing her intention to marry Signor Piazzi. So all of that kind of nightmare is now kind of unleashed for Johnson. Boswell, meanwhile, has gone back to Scotland and he keeps writing to Johnson saying, you know, how are you? I'm very worried about how anxiously seemed about the fate of your eternal soul. Tell me all about it. And Johnson's furious. He doesn't want to talk about it. He doesn't want to put up with Boswell nagging. And so he writes back to Boswell, write to me often, but write like a man. Then on the third of November, he does something that he never does. He complains to Boswell about his health. He says, I feel unwell, I feel short of breath. I'm finding it hard to walk. Early December, he draws up his will. He burns a few papers, maybe suggestive. And he falls increasingly to prayer. And on the evening of the 13th of December, he dies, and he's found the next morning in his bed. And his passing is marked as a very solemn national occasion.
他被安葬在威斯敏斯特教堂。约书亚·雷诺兹是抬棺人之一，悼词由埃德蒙·伯克发表。鲍斯韦尔没有参加仪式。他在苏格兰。消息在他去世四天后传到他那里。他陷入了彻底的痛苦之中。在约翰逊葬礼八天后，也就是12月28日。他仍然可以在日记中写下他对约翰逊去世的不敢相信。但他现在也感到巨大的压力，因为每个人都知道他一直在为约翰逊的传记准备笔记。
He's buried in Westminster Abbey. Joshua Reynolds is among the poor bearers, and the eulogy is delivered by Edmund Burke. Boswell is not at the service. He is up in Scotland. The news reaches him four days after Johnson's death. And he is thrown utterly into misery. And eight days after Johnson's funeral, so that's the 28th of December. He can still write in his journal his sense of disbelief that Johnson is dead. But he also feels now under the most massive pressure because everyone knows that he has been preparing notes for a biography of Johnson.
我认为鲍斯韦尔本人觉得他直到这一刻的整个人生都是为那项伟大的任务做准备。所以出版商意识到了这一点，他们写信给他，说，你知道，你能立刻给我们一些东西吗？现在是12月。一位出版商说，你知道，二月份给我400页。我想有两个原因。一个是，他想为他伟大的朋友制作一个纪念碑。你知道，他觉得这项任务已经指派给他了。他会卖出更多的副本。
And I think that Boswell himself feels that his entire life up until this moment had been preparation for that great task. And so publishers are aware of this and they write to him and say, you know, can you get us something immediately? It's December. One publisher says, you know, get me 400 pages by February. And I guess a couple of reasons for this. One is that he wants to produce a memorial to his great friend. You know, he feels this task has been appointed to him. He'll sell more copies.
越接近约翰逊的去世。这是名声的巅峰，但人们会开始忘记约翰逊。是的，人们会忘记，但也可能有竞争对手，其他竞争对手在写约翰逊的书。是的，当然，皮亚齐夫人是其中的佼佼者。所以鲍斯韦尔对此非常焦虑，他想，好吧，我最好的做法是去伦敦，在那里开始工作，这是一个糟糕的计划。因为当然，鲍斯韦尔一到伦敦，就开始表现得像他在伦敦时的样子。所以他出去看热气球。他去了贝德拉姆，有趣的是，那是疯子被锁起来的地方。
The closer it is to Johnson's death. This is peak fame, but people will start to forget Johnson. Yeah, people will forget, but also there might be competitors, other rivals working on Johnson books. Yeah, of course, and Mrs Piotzzi, chief among them. So Boswell is very anxious about this and he thinks, well, probably the best thing for me to do is to go down to London and start work there, which is terrible plan. Because of course, the moment Boswell arrives in London, he starts behaving as Boswell does in London. So he goes out to watch a hot air balloon. He goes to Bedlam, interestingly, the place where the lunatics are chained up.
他最终和一个囚犯唱了一首歌，鲍斯韦尔本人形容这首歌非常动听。鲍斯韦尔真是个混蛋，不是吗？然后他和两个穿着红外套的妓女在圣保罗教堂墓地喝醉了。他喝得太醉了，以至于没注意到自己的口袋被掏了。他摔倒了，不得不由两个陌生人扶回家。而这一切都无助于他写传记。就这样继续下去。几个月过去了，然后是几年。
And he ends up singing a song with an inmate that Boswell himself describes as having been very pretty. Boswell is such a dog, isn't he? He then gets drunk with a couple of prostitutes who are wearing red coats in the churchyard of St. Paul's. He's so drunk that he doesn't notice his pocket being picked. He falls over and he has to be helped home by a pair of strangers. and none of this is helping him to write his biography. And it goes on like this. And the months pass and then the years.
鲍斯韦尔的生活开始分崩离析，正如他所担心的那样，约翰逊走了。所以他最终完全离开了爱丁堡，试图在伦敦成为一名大律师，结果是一场灾难。你知道，他不懂英国法律。这完全没希望。他试图在议会中获得一个席位，
And Boswell's life begins to fall apart at the seams, as he had worried it would with Johnson gone. So he ends up leaving Edinburgh altogether, trying to set up as a barrister in London, and it's a disaster. You know, he doesn't know English law. It's absolutely hopeless. He tries to secure a seat in Parliament,
结果被他希望担任他赞助人的贵族羞辱。他的妻子患上了肺结核，鲍斯韦尔忽视了她。她随后去世了，他陷入了悲痛和内疚之中。当这一切发生时，鲍斯韦尔生活中的所有这些灾难性发展，在出版方面，正如书商们所担心的那样。许多约翰逊的传记开始出现。其中第一本，出版于1786年春天，是由皮亚齐夫人写的。它非常刻薄，相当贫乏。它非常痛苦，反映了她与约翰逊关系的破裂。
and he ends up humiliated by the aristocrat that he'd been hoping would serve as his patron. His wife falls ill with tuberculosis and Boswell neglects her. She then dies and he's then prostrated with grief and guilt. And while all this is going on, all these kind of catastrophic developments in Boswell's life, on the publishing front, it's exactly as the booksellers had feared. Lots of biographies of Johnson start appearing. And the first of these, which was published in spring 1786, was by Mrs. Piotse. And it was very waspish and pretty impoverished. And it was very embittered and it reflected the breakdown in her relations with Johnson.
你知道，因此它有八卦的暗示。所以它，你知道，相当受欢迎。是的。然后在1787年，有一本非常自命不凡的正式传记，声称是权威的。那是约翰逊遗嘱的执行人之一，一位名叫约翰·霍金斯爵士的律师写的。而且，你知道，它非常僵硬。但同样，它被作为权威推销的事实，对鲍斯韦尔来说是一个巨大的焦虑。
You know, and therefore it has the hint of gossip. And so it's, you know, it's pretty popular. Yeah. And then in 1787, there's a very pompous formal biography, which is claimed to be definitive. And that was written by one of the executors of Johnson's will, a lawyer by the name of Sir John Hawkins. And, you know, it's very stiff. But again, the fact that it's being marketed as definitive, it's a massive, you know, anxiety. for Boswell.
1780年代变成了1790年代，鲍斯韦尔仍然没有迹象表明这本长期承诺、长期期待的约翰逊传。所以他的朋友和敌人都没完没了地，你知道，朋友们说，快点。他的敌人说，哈哈，你没用，你是个老酒鬼，你永远不会出版它。确实，他自己生活的混乱，你知道，嫖娼、酗酒和日益增长的债务。
And the 1780s become the 1790s, and still from Boswell, there is no sign of this long promised, long anticipated life of Johnson. And so both his friends and his enemies are endlessly, you know, the friends are saying, get a move on. His enemies are saying, ha, ha, ha, you're useless, you're an old drunk, you're never going to publish it. And it's true that the chaos of his own life, you know, the whoring and the drinking and the growing debts.
嗯，他喝了很多酒，不是吗？到这个时候已经大量了。我的意思是，这些显然是他觉得很难完成他的书的原因。但我认为这也归因于别的东西。那就是一种感觉，实际上他的传记，他正处于伟大事业的边缘，他生活中的其他一切都是灾难。但如果他能把这本传记写好，那么这将是他的纪念碑。你知道，他将取得一些伟大的成就。
Well, he is drinking a lot, isn't he? massive amounts by this point. I mean, these are clearly factors why he's finding it hard to finish his book. But I think it is also due to something more. And that is a sense that actually with his biography, he is on the verge of something great, that everything else in his life is a disaster. But if he can get this biography right, then that will be his memorial. You know, he will have achieved something wonderful.
他的野心既简单又傲慢。写一种从未写过的传记，用他在传记引言中最终写下的词来描绘约翰逊，比迄今为止活过的任何人都更完整。所以他让罗伯特·卡罗，那个写这些关于林登·约翰逊生平的6000页书的人。他让他看起来像个小册子作者，不是吗？因为鲍斯韦尔想核对每一个事实，他想和约翰逊的每一个同事交谈。他想写出完整的权威传记，毫无疑问，没有未问或未回答的问题。
And his ambition is as simple as it's hubristic. to write a biography of a kind that has never been written for, to portray Johnson in the words that he ends up putting in his introduction to the biography, more completely than any man who has ever yet lived. So he makes Robert Caro, who writes these 6,000-page books about the life of Lyndon Johnson. He makes him look like a mere pamphleteer, doesn't he? Because Boswell wants to check every fact, he wants to talk to every associate of Johnson's. he wants to write the complete life definitive, no question, unasked or unanswered.
鲍斯韦尔的约翰逊传没有罗伯特·卡罗的长，但罗伯特·卡罗绝对是鲍斯韦尔的继承人。本质上，今天写传记的每个人都是鲍斯韦尔的继承人，因为他确立了每一个细节都很重要的模板。是的。你必须确定每一个细节。你不能只是重复道听途说。所以这需要大量的工作和努力。但我认为，你刚才谈到鲍斯韦尔担心为什么约翰逊在生命的最后几个月里认为自己会被诅咒？作为传记作者和朋友，鲍斯韦尔也担心这一点。所以他试图工作，你知道，如果他的传记要完整，那么他就不能掩盖这一点。他需要设法处理这个问题。所以他在脑海中徘徊
Boswell's life of Johnson is not as long as Robert Carrow's, but Robert Carrow is definitely the heir of Boswell. And essentially everyone who writes a biography today is Boswell's heir, because he has established the template that every detail matters. Yeah. You have to be sure of every detail. You can't just repeat hearsay. So that takes a lot of work and effort. But I think also, you were talking about Boswell worrying about why is Johnson thinking he's damned in the final months of his life? And Boswell is worried about that, I think, as a biographer, as well as a friend. And so he is trying to work, you know, if his biography is going to be complete, then he can't veil that. He needs to kind of get to grips with that. And so he's kind of roving in his mind all
各种可能性。例如，约翰逊的信仰在生命的最后几个月里是否动摇了？你知道，他是否担心自己会发疯，会变成疯子？或者，正如你所建议的，是某种性的记忆，也许，这导致了他的羞耻，让他担心自己可能会被诅咒？鲍斯韦尔并没有排除任何这些可能性，因为他一直在做研究。他知道，作为一个年轻人，实际上约翰逊有过宗教怀疑。所以大卫·加里克，伟大的作家，鲍斯韦尔最老的朋友。他说约翰逊年轻时确实有宗教怀疑，我们已经看到约翰逊确实害怕陷入疯狂。而且，即使从约翰逊自己说的话中也很明显，经常拿它开玩笑，
kinds of possibilities. So had Johnson's faith, for instance, been wavering in the final months of his life? You know, was he worrying that he might go insane, might become a lunatic? Or, as you suggested, was it the memory of something sexual, perhaps, which had been causing him shame and making him worry that he might be damned? And Boswell doesn't discount any of these possibilities because he's been doing his research. And he knows that as a young man, actually, Johnson had had religious doubts. So David Garrick, the great writer, Boswell's oldest friend. He'd said Johnson did have religious doubts as a young man, we've seen how Johnson did indeed dread being plunged into madness. And also, it's evident even from things that Johnson said himself, often making a kind of jest out of it,
他确实感到他的道德感和性欲之间存在持续的张力。所以你提到了那句关于他去后台告诉加里克的精彩台词，我不打算来这里，因为，是什么，你女演员的白皙胸部和丝绸长袜激起了我的色欲。但他也有这种美妙的短语，如果我没有职责，也没有对未来的参考，我会花我的一生在邮车里和一位漂亮的女人轻快地行驶。所以鲍斯韦尔自己的直觉，他最终决定这实际上就是约翰逊所担心的。所以他在传记中写道，他怀疑约翰逊年轻时曾找过妓女，或者正如鲍斯韦尔本人所说，曾
that he did feel a constant tension between his sense of morality and his sexual desire. So you mentioned that wonderful line about him going backstage and telling Garrick, I'm not going to become here because, what is it, the white bosoms and silk stockings of your actresses aroused my amorous propensities. But he also had this kind of wonderful phrase, if I had no duties and no reference to futurity, I would spend my life in driving briskly in a post-chaise with a pretty woman. So Broswell's own hunch, he ends up deciding that actually this is what Johnson had been worrying about. And so he writes in the biography that his suspicion that as a young man Johnson had turned to prostitutes, or as Boswell himself puts it, had been
被引导进行了一些放纵，这引起了他美德的极大困扰。头脑。所以，我的意思是，我想这是一种表达方式。但还有另一种可能性。这是1949年一位名叫凯瑟琳·鲍德斯通的学者提出的一种可能性，也许约翰逊脑子里的是他与思雷尔夫人之间萨德式关系的记忆。所以在这个系列节目中一直有暗示。所以在那封开场信中。约翰逊谈到了那种你非常清楚如何使其成为快乐的奴隶制。思雷尔夫人写信给他，送他去加入鲍斯韦尔的赫布里底群岛之旅。不要因为没有充分使用鞭子而与你的女教师争吵。现在那个挂锁和链子
led into some indulgences which occasioned much distressed his virtue. mind. So, I mean, that's one way of putting it, I guess. But there is another possibility. And this is one that came to light in 1949 when a scholar called Catherine Baldestone suggested that perhaps what was on Johnson's mind were memories of a sadomasochistic relationship that he had had with Mrs. Thrail. So there have been hints of that being dropped throughout this episode. So in that opening letter. Johnson had spoken of that slavery which you know so well how to make a happy one. And Mrs. Thrail had written to him, sending him on his way to join Boswell for their tour of the Hebrides. Do not quarrel with your governess for not using the rod enough. Now that padlock and chain
约翰逊买的那个，他把它作为礼物送给了思雷尔夫人。思雷尔夫人在日记中写道，约翰逊说，一个女人在25岁到45岁之间有这样的力量，如果她愿意，她可以把一个男人绑在柱子上鞭打他。然后她继续说，好吧，我知道约翰逊意识到这一点。然后就让它悬在那里。这是一种可能性吗？我的意思是，我认为说它可能是并不时代错误。威尔士的恶习再次抬头，不是吗？
that Johnson had bought, he made a gift of that to Mrs. Thrail. And Mrs. Strail made a note in her diary, says Johnson, a woman has such power between the ages of 25 and 45 that she may tie a man to a post and whip him if she will. And she then goes on to say, well, I know for a fact that Johnson is aware of this. And just kind of leaves that hanging. So is it a possibility? I mean, I think it's not anachronistic to say it might have been. La Vise Galois, the Welsh vice rears its head again, no?
萨德侯爵在法国出现了，即使在思雷尔夫人写那封信的时候。这里发生了什么？这是，我认为这太疯狂了。我认为这只是三件不相关的事情。挂锁隐喻结合在一起。我同意。我认为即使其中有这种成分，我认为它也没有付诸行动。
The Marquis de Sard is on the scene in France, even as Mrs. Raoul is writing that. What's going on here? Is this, I think this is bonkers. I think this is just three unrelated things. Padlock metaphors yoked together. I agree. And I think that even if there was an element of that to it, I think it was unacted on.
我也认为约翰逊年轻时没有和妓女睡觉。但我认为像吉米·卡特一样，他在心里感受到了欲望，并为此感到内疚。鲍斯韦尔无法理解一个人可能会因为想去嫖娼而感到内疚，因为鲍斯韦尔实际上每天都在这样做。所以我认为鲍斯韦尔误读了约翰逊感到内疚的原因。但鲍斯韦尔难道不把约翰逊的折磨视为他没有以某种方式搞砸的迹象，而是提醒他他的想象力有多么伟大吗，
I also think that Johnson didn't sleep with prostitutes as a young man. But I think that like Jimmy Carter, he felt lust in his heart and felt guilty about that. And it's beyond Boswell's ability to comprehend that someone might feel guilty about wanting to go with prostitution. prostitutes because Boswell is doing it literally every day. So I think Boswell is misreading what Johnson felt guilty about myself. But doesn't Boswell see Johnson's torments as signs not that he's screwed up in some way, but signs of a reminder of just how great his imagination is,
他能被他甚至没有做过的事情的怀疑所折磨的事实。鲍斯韦尔有这个美妙的隐喻，不是吗？一个非常、非常汤姆·霍兰式的隐喻，关于罗马的斗兽场。是的，这是一个非常、非常美丽、强大的隐喻。他的思想类似于巨大的圆形剧场，罗马的斗兽场。中心站着他的判断力，像一个强大的角斗士，与那些像竞技场里的野兽一样，在细胞里到处都是，准备被释放到他身上的恐惧作斗争。冲突后，他把它们赶回了巢穴，但没有杀死它们，它们仍然在攻击他。所以这是约翰逊一生都在进行的战斗。我认为
the fact that he can be tormented by doubt about something that he didn't even do. Basel has this wonderful metaphor, doesn't he? A very, very Tom Holland metaphor about the Colosseum in Rome. Yeah, it's such a, it's such a beautiful, powerful metaphor. His mind resembled the vast amphitheatre, the Coliseum at Rome. In the centre stood his judgment, which like a mighty gladiator, combated those apprehensions that, like the wild beasts of the arena, were all around in cells, ready to be let out upon him. After a conflict, he drove them back into their dens, but not killing them, they were still a assailing him. So this is a fight that Johnson is undertaking his entire life. And I think the
鲍斯韦尔最终写的约翰逊传的开创性成就是，那本传记的读者不需要相信这一点，因为鲍斯韦尔对约翰逊的描绘最终是如此宽广、如此详细、如此富有同情心、如此丰富，以至于传记的读者可以自己感受到这一点。这就是为什么它是一本如此感人的书。你感受到了约翰逊的缺陷以及他是如何克服它们的。这就是他伟大的所在。它是沉浸式的。
groundbreaking achievement of the biography that Boswell ends up writing of Johnson is that readers of that biography do not need to take this on trust because Boswell's portrayal of Johnson ends up being so capacious, so detailed, so empathetic, so compassionate, so rich, that readers of the life can feel that for themselves. It's why it's such a moving book. You feel the flaws of Johnson and how he overcame them. That's what his greatness lies in. It's immersive.
它引人入胜。它在内部是一致的，这是当时之前的传记所没有的。它在心理上很敏锐。但它有矛盾、复杂和古怪的空间，以及所有这些东西。所以你确实感觉到，我同意你的看法。你觉得你得到的是一个完整、圆润、复杂的人的形象，而不是人们迄今为止所做的那种稍微简单化、流线型的肖像，包括古典肖像等等。
It's compelling. It's internally coherent in a way that biographies up to that point were not. It's psychologically acute. But it has room for contradiction and for complexity and for eccentricity and all of those kinds of things. So you do feel, I agree with you. You feel like you're getting the picture of a complete, rounded, complicated human being, rather than the sort of slightly simplistic, streamlined portraits that people had done up to this point, including kind of classical portraits and whatnot.
没有讽刺的感觉，不是吗？没有。最重要的是，它非常有趣。我的意思是，约翰逊的谈话很精彩，鲍斯韦尔保留了它。所以你可以一页又一页地读。它，我的意思是，它非常令人愉快。所以当它出来时，你知道，这本传记已经等了七年了，每个人都说，这太棒了。
There's no sense of caricature about it, is there? No. And on top of that, it is insanely entertaining. I mean, Johnson's conversation is brilliant, and Boswell has preserved it. And so you can read page after page after page. It's like, I mean, it is so enjoyable. And so when it comes out, you know, there's been a seven-year wait for this, this biography, and everyone says, this is brilliant.
我的意思是，这太不可思议了。我们从未读过这样的东西。我认为我们已经习惯了今天传记的形式，也许很难重现人们在阅读它时感受到的兴奋、怀疑和享受。鲍斯韦尔几乎在一夜之间被奉为传记作者中的莎士比亚，最伟大的。关于它出版的时间只有一个问题。
I mean, this is incredible. We've never read anything like that. And I think we're so habituated to the form that biography has taken today that perhaps it can be hard to recapture the sense of excitement and disbelief and enjoyment that people felt on reading it. And Boswell almost overnight was in. enshrined as the kind of the Shakespeare, the goat of biographers. Just one question about the time that it comes out.
它出版于1791年。它是终极英国人的肖像，一个几乎自觉地体现了实用主义、常识、小写c保守主义的人，人们喜欢将其与英国性格等同起来。你认为它在法国大革命开始两年后出版，并且在两年后，我想是这样，英国将陷入与革命法国的战争，而这种英国人的肖像会产生共鸣，这对它的接受有影响吗？
It came out in 1791. And it is the portrait of the ultimate Englishman, somebody who almost self-consciously incarnates the pragmatism, the common sense, the small sea conservatism that people like to equate with the English character. Do you think it makes a difference to its reception that it comes out two years after the French Revolution has begun? And two years before, I think it is, Britain is going to end up in. war with revolutionary France and that a portrait of an Englishman of this kind would resonate
它出版于1791年。它是终极英国人的写照，一个几乎是有意识地体现了实用主义、常识以及人们喜欢与英国性格等同起来的小写c保守主义的人。你认为它在法国大革命开始两年后出版，以及在英国最终与革命后的法国开战前两年出版，这对它的反响有影响吗？这种英国人的肖像是否会引起共鸣？
with people in a way that might not have done at a different point. I think that must be the case. I think that Johnson is an intellectual, funny, warm-hearted John Bull and that's exactly what people in Britain, England, perhaps more particularly, want. And that's what Boswell has given them. You know, it's not just down to Johnson. It is also down to Boswell. And I think that that's what makes them, you know, as a pair, such kind of irresistible subjects for a history podcast, because Johnson, I mean, he continues to live. There are lots of people who have been like Johnson, kind of great literary lions. Nobody remembers them. But he continues to live thanks to Boswell in a way that, in my opinion, no one in history before that biography lives
以一种在其他时间点可能无法实现的方式与人们建立联系。我认为事实必然如此。我认为约翰逊是一位知识渊博、风趣幽默、热心肠的“约翰牛”式人物，而这正是英国人，或许更确切地说是英格兰人，所渴望的。这也是鲍斯韦尔带给他们的。你知道，这不仅仅归功于约翰逊，也归功于鲍斯韦尔。我认为正是这一点使他们这对组合成为历史播客中令人无法抗拒的主题，因为约翰逊，我的意思是，他依然鲜活。历史上有很多像约翰逊那样伟大的文学巨匠，但没人记得他们。但他多亏了鲍斯韦尔，以一种在我看来历史上没有任何人在那部传记之前所能达到的方式，依然鲜活地存在着。
today. He is the oldest complete portrait of a person that we have. Well, I was about to say it's the completeness. That's the thing, isn't it? I mean, there are great characters in history. There's, I don't know, Augustus or Henry the 8th or Oliver Cromwell or whoever it might be. But we only see them, you know, we see very partial pictures of them at best. But Johnson, you feel like you know the man. You feel like he could be your friend, like you know him that well. Yeah. And it's not just Johnson, of course, because, you know, we're also seeing the people that he's dining with, you know, in private dinners or in London taverns or on the Hobarties or whatever. And these scenes are so vivid. So Adam Sisman, who's written a wonderful book, Boswell's presumptuous task about how Boswell went set about writing this biography. He's written brilliantly on how Boswell frames these scenes of kind of Johnson having conversations with his friends as scenes in a play. and why he took such care over them. And Sisman writes, he knew that they were what made his biography distinct from any other.
今天。他是我们所拥有的关于一个人最完整的肖像。嗯，我正想说这就是完整性。这就是关键所在，不是吗？我的意思是，历史上有很多伟大的人物。比如奥古斯都、亨利八世、奥利弗·克伦威尔或其他任何人。但我们看到的只是他们，你知道，充其量只是他们非常片面的形象。但对于约翰逊，你会觉得你了解这个人。你会觉得他就像你的朋友，你对他非常了解。是的。当然，这不仅仅是因为约翰逊，因为我们还看到了与他共进晚餐的人，无论是在私人晚宴上，还是在伦敦的酒馆里，或者在赫布里底群岛等等。这些场景是如此生动。亚当·西斯曼写了一本精彩的书《鲍斯韦尔的冒昧任务》，讲述了鲍斯韦尔是如何着手撰写这部传记的。他出色地描写了鲍斯韦尔如何将约翰逊与朋友交谈的场景构建成戏剧中的场景，以及他为何如此精心雕琢这些场景。西斯曼写道，他知道正是这些场景使他的传记与众不同。
But I think that, you know, we can push that analogy perhaps even further. Because in the episode we did on the tour of the Hebrides, we cast Boswell as a kind of documentary maker. And I think that reading these scenes of Johnson talking is as close to having fly-on-the-wall documentary footage from the 18th century as we get. It's that incredible to read. And these are not scenes from a play because they actually happened. Boswell recorded them and put them in his journals and reworked them.
但我认为，我们可以把这个类比推得更远。因为在我们制作的关于赫布里底群岛之旅的那一集中，我们将鲍斯韦尔塑造为一种纪录片制作人。我认为阅读这些约翰逊交谈的场景，就像我们能从18世纪获得的“墙上苍蝇”式纪录片镜头一样接近真实。读起来真是令人难以置信。这些不是戏剧中的场景，因为它们确实发生过。鲍斯韦尔记录了它们，把它们写进日记，并进行了润色。
And you can read them and there they are. And it's a tribute, not just to Johnson though, but to Boswell, right? Yeah, completely. I mean, you say they're scenes from a documentary. I mean, they're not because they're literary constructs. And Boswell is a great writer. I mean, Boswell is a brilliant writer with a brilliant writer. judgment of, you know, when to stop the anecdote, how much detail to go into, all of those
你可以阅读它们，它们就在那里。这不仅是对约翰逊的致敬，也是对鲍斯韦尔的致敬，对吧？是的，完全正确。我的意思是，你说它们是纪录片中的场景。我的意思是，它们不是，因为它们是文学建构。鲍斯韦尔是一位伟大的作家。我的意思是，鲍斯韦尔是一位才华横溢的作家，他对何时结束轶事、需要深入到什么程度的细节，都有着极其出色的判断力，所有这些
kinds of things. I mean, he's obviously recreating conversations from memory, and he seems to have amazing memory for that. But also Boswell, I mean, Boswell's a pretty bad man in some ways, but he has a great enthusiasm for life, doesn't he? He loves being himself and being alive and the world, and he takes such boyish pleasure in it that it's irrepressible. You can disapprove of his conduct, which is often pretty poor, while at the same time, you know, finding him fun and finding his world really fun. And also, of course, reflect the fact that we only know how badly Boswell behaves because he actually writes it down in these journals. So these journals were lost. People didn't even know they existed for a century and more. And then they were
这类事情。我的意思是，他显然是凭记忆重构对话，而且他似乎有惊人的记忆力。但鲍斯韦尔，我的意思是，鲍斯韦尔在某些方面是个相当糟糕的人，但他对生活有着巨大的热情，不是吗？他热爱做自己，热爱活着，热爱这个世界，他从中获得了如此孩子气的快乐，以至于无法抑制。你可以不赞同他的行为，这些行为往往相当糟糕，但同时，你又会觉得他很有趣，觉得他的世界真的很有趣。当然，这也反映了一个事实，即我们之所以知道鲍斯韦尔的行为有多糟糕，是因为他确实把这些写进了日记里。所以这些日记曾经丢失了。人们甚至在一个多世纪里都不知道它们的存在。然后它们
found in very weird circumstances in the 20th century. And people who want to know more about that, more about how Boswell might have recorded all the details that goes into the life of Johnson. I will be talking to Adam Sissman on a bonus. In fact, by the time you listen to this, it may already have gone out. But just to end by saying that I think that, you know, there are kind of an amazing literary duo, so Don Quoteo, Sancha Panza, or Sherlock Holmes, and Dr. Watson. And Johnson and Boswell are up there in that kind of pantheon. But the amazing thing is they're real.
在20世纪以非常奇怪的情况被发现。那些想了解更多信息，想了解更多关于鲍斯韦尔如何记录约翰逊生活细节的人，我将在加更节目中与亚当·西斯曼交谈。事实上，当你听到这里时，它可能已经发布了。但最后我想说，我认为他们是一对令人惊叹的文学二人组，就像堂吉诃德和桑丘·潘沙，或者福尔摩斯和华生。约翰逊和鲍斯韦尔在那个万神殿中占有一席之地。但令人惊奇的是，他们是真实存在的。
They're not invented. But they have that kind of character of kind of timeless archetypes. And I think that to read Boswell's life of Johnson essentially is to come as close as is humanly possible to overhearing the 18th century. And to read it is to experience a form of time travel. Well, to think about Johnson and Boswell always reminds me of, I once saw a lecture online by Neil Ferguson, the sometimes controversial historian. And it's a sort of welcome lecture that he does for students. He's talking about his love of history. And he says, people who I think of as great friends of mine have been dead for 200 years.
他们不是虚构的。但他们具有那种永恒原型的特征。我认为阅读鲍斯韦尔的《约翰逊传》本质上就是尽可能接近地去偷听18世纪。阅读它就是体验一种时间旅行。嗯，想到约翰逊和鲍斯韦尔总是让我想起，我曾经在网上看过尼尔·弗格森（那位有时颇具争议的历史学家）的讲座。那是他为学生做的欢迎讲座。他谈到了他对历史的热爱。他说，我视为挚友的人已经去世200年了。
And I've encountered them through studying history and the pages of history. And I feel like I know them better than I know people I see every day. And I love them. And I love being reacquainted with them and being in their company. And that's one of the beauties of history. And Johnson and Buzzwell are like that, aren't they? They're such irresistible characters that you feel, you know them, and you relish every moment that you spend in their company.
我通过研究历史和历史书页与他们相遇。我觉得我比了解每天见到的人更了解他们。我爱他们。我喜欢与他们重逢，喜欢与他们为伴。这就是历史的魅力之一。约翰逊和鲍斯韦尔就是这样，不是吗？他们是如此令人无法抗拒的人物，以至于你觉得你了解他们，并且珍惜与他们在一起的每一刻。
Absolutely. And if this series encourages anybody to read Boswell's life of Johnson or even some of his journals, then it won't have been in vain. Oh, I definitely won't have been in vain, Tom. So that is Johnson and Boswell. What a wonderful story. And we're going to be doing something completely different next time. So next time we will be venturing back to 19th century America for the rather darker story. of the Ku Klux Klan. So, Tom, thank you so much. What an immersive journey into Georgian, London that was, and indeed to Scotland, and most of all, to Wales. So on that Welsh bombshell, we say thank you very much and goodbye. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
绝对是这样。如果这个系列能鼓励任何人去阅读鲍斯韦尔的《约翰逊传》甚至他的一些日记，那么它就没有白费。哦，绝对不会白费，汤姆。这就是约翰逊和鲍斯韦尔。多么精彩的故事。下一次我们将做一些完全不同的事情。所以下一次我们将冒险回到19世纪的美国，讲述一个关于三K党更为黑暗的故事。所以，汤姆，非常感谢你。那是一次多么沉浸式的乔治亚时代伦敦之旅，当然还有苏格兰，最重要的是，威尔士。带着那个威尔士的重磅炸弹，我们说声非常感谢并再见。再见。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。